e
everybody in the L in view of the
weather if any of the committee members
feel the need to leave early please do
we don't want you uh crashing on the
all right
so I'm opening the public hearing on
Whitley thank you madam chair and good
morning members of the committee for the
record my name is Becky Whitley see if I
can see everyone here uh and I'm honored
to serve Senate District 15 which
includes the wonderful communities of Bo
ConEd Penacook and hopkington uh today
I'm honored to introduce Senate Bill 337
which contains some technical portions
from the momus bill last year Senate
Bill 175 that were just inadvertently
left out of hb2 last year so if you
remember um or you may not sort of know
the full procedure of what happened with
the mnus S SP 175 last year as the
Senate's practice okay so Senate Bill
175 was introduced last year with strong
bipartisan support it was a
comprehensive Bill to address maternal
health and um a portion of that bill was
to add Doula coverage and lactation
coverage uh lactation service coverage
um and other things to the Medicaid
Program and for those folks those
providers to actually build Medicaid we
had to have a process through oplc um
for those folks to get certified that's
just the way that our Medicaid uh
program works we we add the service and
then you have to make sure that the
providers are certified so we said to
doulas and lactation service providers
that you don't have to be certified to
practice in New Hampshire but if you
want to build Medicaid you do have to go
through oplc because that is just our
process and Henry Litman or someone else
from the Department can sort of describe
that so what you see in 337 was just
sort of those that technical piece to
add to give oplc authority to do that
but in the hustle and bustle the Senate
passed Senate Bill 175 and as is our
practice we tabled the bill for
inclusion in the budget into hb2
everything got included except for this
little technical piece that was left out
inadvertently um and apologies to the
house for that um Medicaid director
Henry Litman had elevated this issue to
me at the beginning of or at the end of
last year and we're just here today to
make that technical fix um so again as
we worked out last year we don't want a
requirement for all duas and lactation
uh service providers it's only for those
who want to participate in the medical
in the Medicaid Program so um an
amendment was emailed to the committee
and I do have copies and um all the
amendment does was is actually just
removes credent like names of
credentials for lactation service
providers so you will see so duelas and
lactation service providers there's a
whole host of credentials different
bodies that credential them and on the
Doula side we didn't think it was
appropriate to pick that in the statute
one credential over the other that was a
process that was more appropriate in
oplc and with the Medicaid Program so we
inadvertently did that on the lactation
service side so you'll see that this
amendment just removes mention of actual
credentials right and so it just says
that oplc shall determine the
certification if that makes sense um I
have copies here and I'm happy to take
any questions um would the chair like me
to pass out the amendment it will help
us a lot uh I have a question you can
think about while you're passing them
out we have gotten a great number of
communications from people who are
apparently in other organizations that
certify lactation consultants and your
amendment is designed to say any of the
professional groups that do certify
lactation Consultants are fine with us
um so we're just taking mention out in
the statute that we don't think it's
appropriate to like just list two of the
credentials in the statute we think
that's more appropriate in the Medicaid
Program and the administrative process
not appropriate for the statute so yes
and I think a lot of the uh
correspondence that you've received is
very valid we should never have put it
was actually uh something that we should
never have put in in the first place
it's really not appropriate for a
statute to to name various credentials
well actually many of our licensing
statutes do name the credentialing
organizations which is why we weren't
surprised to see it here okay okay but
this
eliminates the conflict between the two
different groups that offer slightly
different but adequate
credentials yes so it all it does is
authorize oplc to determine the
process okay Y and work with the various
credentialing bodies and that will
happen through
rules all right are there any other
questions representative leus uh thank
you I'm not sure if there might be
somebody else here better able to answer
this but I'd like to have some feel for
if there's somebody from
oplc on what sorts of things uh they
would expect to put in rules around the
certification um I don't I'm not sure
don't see anybody from oplc just at the
moment yeah and I would suggest we are
expecting them later in because they're
the next Bill's all about them so ah
wait a second we will as as soon as uh
when please put in a card and when we uh
get to you we'll we'll ask that question
um and Madam chair if I may um the I
would also suggest calling up um Lisa s
from the Department who um is also not
put in a card so so I would suggest yeah
hearing from her because she's really
the expert in this field I am not the
expert she's the public health person um
who is working with the Medicaid
department on these various credentials
she's also a lactation service provider
herself so she might be the next person
to speak with along with with OP PLC
folks all right thank you I would
appreciate that all right are there any
committee no thank you very much Senator
thank you madam chair I uh will stay for
a little bit but I do have to go back to
my own committee thank you very
much yes we have at least two members
yeah just hand it in to somebody we'll
along okay thank
hallisy
thank you I'm Brenda golden H the agency
council with oplc um I don't oplc um
doesn't take a position on the bill um I
don't know if I have any answers to any
questions that anybody might have but I
would be um sure to take them along and
uh make sure that any questions get
answered in terms of um how we would
process this all right represent laus
thank you I I know the uh the details on
the requirement certification would go
through the whole room making process
but I was wondering if there's you know
some feel for the sorts of requirements
um that oplc would expect to uh to put
in place I do not at this time and um it
was uh kind of a surprised to me that an
amendment had been um had been submitted
today so I think that um once we have a
chance to absorb uh the removal of the
credentialing agencies and how we would
uh how we would then credential the
people would might be a better answer
but I could certainly um have somebody
address that for you and um see if we
can get a more thorough answer all right
thank you all right any other
questions thank you and um we've got a
couple of professional organizations
that will no doubt tell you how uh
appropriate their certifications are
Sira
you need turn the mic on there you go
good morning my name is Lisa sorice I
work in the New Hampshire division of
Public Health Services for the
Department um there is not a
representative here from Medicaid this
morning but I can help answer some
questions um thank you to Senator
Whitley for bringing forward um this
legislation it is because of Medicaid
reimbursement that certification um
needs to happen for both douas and
lactation service providers there is
opportunity currently under Medicaid for
lactation services to be provided under
currently licensed professionals right
now such as Healthcare Providers or
nursing the intent of this legislation
was to allow for those beneficiaries of
Medicaid to seek lactation service
support through
Medicaid outside of just their immediate
primary care provider so such as with an
international board certified lactation
consultant it was brought forward in the
other
chamber that there are other
credentialing agencies that certify
other lactation education providers and
so it started to get a little confusing
between the difference between
credentialing bodies in lactation
service providers there is one clinical
lactation service professional that
exists and that's an international board
certified lactation consultant those are
your folks who typically are working
inside the hospitals providing immediate
lactation care for moms Post delivery
there are also some that work in private
practice or work in pediatric offices
that are really servicing those families
that have complex lactation issues
beyond your basic need of typically what
can be solved in your provider's office
there is another group of like ation
service providers which fall under our
educational arm if you will and those
folks are working inside of our Wick
programs also inside of some doctor's
offices home visiting programs providing
basic breastfeeding management and
education to families and so the the
information that was put forth in the
amendment of removing the credentialing
agencies is because there are a lot of
credentialing agencies that oversee our
lactation Educators there is only one
that oversees International board
certified lactation Consultants but
rather than um in statute we are willing
at the department to work with oplc
obviously within Medicaid um to identify
what those credentialing agencies are to
make sure that lactation services are
available for Medicaid
moms so so if I understand you correctly
the group you mentioned is for
essentially working within hospitals and
for immediate Pro and severe problems
with nursing yes and the other
credentials are for out in the community
with Education and Training and help
with less s less serious medical issues
primarily yes okay thank you I I think
that makes sense other
questions representative
shu
thank you madam chair U Can you tell us
are there major impediments to folks
that are working in these other fields
certification I don't know about
impediments but it's certainly a longer
process um to become an international
board certified lactation folks that are
ibc's which is the term that we use in
healthcare um have professional
secondary education in a health
discipline they then have on-site
clinical experience that is
required um and then they sit for a exam
it is the same exam that is taken
globally um so this credential is
recognized even outside of the United
States um whereas um some of our other
lactation educator
credentials um tends to be more of an
online course that doesn't require
secondary education first although some
may um and so it's just the depth of the
clinical lactation that they engage in
is is not the
same okay represent leus thank you so is
the Medicare requirement just that they
have state
certification or does it have further
requirements that would U constrain what
oplc would have to choose for as the
requirements it is just for state
certification okay thank you okay so
that we could
certify We could decide to certify
anybody on any
ground
appropriate I don't necessarily know
exactly the answer to that not working
in Medicaid I'm sorry okay thank you
other
right Joyce
Kelly
microphone
pleas very go on now okay great my name
is Joyce Kelly I am a resident of lonia
I am a registered nurse um I speak today
on behalf of the New Hampshire
breastfeeding task
force and I'm going to read my testimony
and we can address some of the questions
you please we'd love to love to have
answers yep so on behalf of the New
Hampshire breastfeeding task Force's
board of directors we oppose Senate Bill
337 relative to duas and lactation
service providers as adopted by the
Senate we are very grateful and
appreciative of the effort put forth by
Senator Whitley in the original Senate
bill to increase access to highquality
perinatal Care for Women in New
Hampshire the New Hampshire
breastfeeding task force is an
educational nonprofit B 1c3 organization
of perinatal professionals working
throughout the state of New Hampshire as
healthc care providers nurses dietitians
Educators and public health
practitioners to educate Advocate and
support policies important to the health
of and well-being of New Hampshire
families the task force supports the
voluntary certification of douas and
international board certified lactation
Consultants which we know is the ibclc
credential by the office of professional
Li ensure a certification for Medicaid
reimbursement however we do not support
including the certified lactation
councel CLC for certification and
Medicaid reimbursement in this
bill this legislation does not
distinguish the differences between the
two very different lactation service
providers credentialed by the American
national standards Institute excuse is
is yes so you're talking about the bill
as amended by Senator Whitley's latest
Amendment
yeah um yeah okay yeah so I was talking
about the original Bill I'm I'm going to
address the um Amendment the original
bill um
spe specifies that the uh the
lactation service providers are
credentials by the international board
right
period so they must be and there's no
other opportunity for certification in
the bill as written but but the CLC was
named
specifically right I in the Senate
version yes right am I miss missing
something
Senator no okay you're I'm a little
confused may I maner yeah yes please um
I understand this this has been a lot of
back and forth the bill as introduced
only had the ic's the Senate Edna
committee amended it to add the clc's my
Amendment removes any
reference to various different
credentials because you know we didn't
think it was appropriate at this point
to make those choices in the statute and
that that was more appropriate at the
administrative Lev well that's
interesting because the version we have
is the ver version as introduced not as
Senate so we don't know what you're
talking about okay I sorry about that um
I hope that clears up some
represent to try and clarify so did the
Senate as a whole adopt that Edna Eda
Amendment they did and I think it we it
was before we really had that rigorous
conversation about all the different
credentials that were on the table and
so that's why this amendment has come in
today because the you know folks you
know it's it's more appropriate to have
that at the administrative I was just
wondering if we actually had the wrong
version it appears we did no no a matter
of fact it looks like there was a screw
up in the Senate because the committee
recommended ought to pass with Amendment
it went to F oh yes and then Finance set
ought to pass so we want to have the
version as amended by the Senate which
is not what we
have okay and yes it
does um they're looking at a different
bill this National commission for
certifying agencies
Etc
but what's
that yes please we need to know what
sorry
yeah so it replaces the entire first
section yeah so so the just
a I'm I I'm sorry for the confusion it
has been a very confusing process but my
understanding so I introduced the bill
we just had reference to the ic's
because that was the original version in
the mnus last year and then the Senate
Edna amended it included mention of the
additional credential and then there
have been a lot of and the Senate
adopted that and then there have been a
lot of conversations since which is why
as I'm introducing it we are removing
reference to specific credentials
because it's more appropriate at this
point because of so many credentials
that are on the table for that to be
done uh within oplc and DHHS and leis I
can have more info about that and
so so Miss Kelly your position is that
you do not accept the uh National
commission for certifying agency
certification no it's the other
one American National standards
Institute it's not that we don't accept
that credentialing agency it's just that
credentialing agency only oversees one
lactation educator provider there are
lots of lactation educator providers
that are overseen by different
credentialing agencies and so the bill
names two credentialing
agencies so to put in statute two
credentialing agencies when there are
other ones felt not right okay so yes
thank you Miss Kelly if you could if you
could please explain the the issue to us
sure so it has so we're talking about
about the ibclc and the CLC
credentialing so we object to the um we
we we support the role of the CLC but
for the purposes of breastfeeding
education which is not require
certification and so the CLC should not
be um certified to independently
practice or submit from for
reimbursement from Medicaid for the foll
reasons okay clc's take a 52-hour course
which is online only and requires no
prerequisite health degree uh they are
not trained to handle complex feeding
situations such as infant suck swallow
abnormalities or infant failure to
thrive um clc's currently do work in
Wick clinics covering all 10 New
Hampshire counties and provide basic
breastfeeding education at no cost to
the state so allowing for reimbursement
through Medicaid is a duplication of
services and could impact the ability of
those clinics to keep the staff so what
do you mean by at no cost to the state
there um those um services are provided
in wi clinics using 100% federal dollars
so they exist that particular credential
does exist and work in wi clinics
already and lastly related to the C CL
ibclc versus CLC um credential there is
a potential conflict of interests to
include one breastfeeding educator
credentialing agency when there are many
options available for that type and
that's what Lisa was talking about okay
uh so the healthy children's project
Academy of lactation policy and practice
has trademarked that credential when
there are other options
available so we feel that they have a um
a significant potential financial
interest in allowing their credential to
be uh included in the in the bill so it
is our recommendation that the house
executive departments and administration
committee amend the current bill to
exclude the language of credentialing
agencies which Senator Whitley talked
about line 7 to1 and allow the oplc to
engage in rulemaking Authority Under RSA
chapter 310 to determine the appropriate
requirements for duela and lactation
service provider certification in New
Hampshire um I welcome your questions
and I want to make sure I didn't forget
anything since I was okay have a couple
of questions all right representative
Brown and then leus so everybody's clear
on that they understand on that
perfectly clear all right thank you
madam chair apparently not perfectly
clear to me my apologies to everyone in
the room a c CL iblc I got that it's
right here in the paper yep and the
American national standards Institute
and the national commission for
certifying agencies is here but please
tell me what CLC is because I must have
missed this CLC is a certified lactation
counselor thank
you okay represent flus I I I think she
just answered my question which was um
would you support the bill with the
amendment yes okay thank you okay thank
you that's any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you very much thanks
hankle hi I'm Brianna hle I am the legal
you need to be closer to the microphone
I'm sorry no that's okay thank you
for um my name is Brianna hle I'm the
legal policy fellow at new futures um
new Futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization um working through um New
Hampshire problems through policy
change um the reason new Futures
supports the bill um the idea for momys
was that there's a maternal mortality
crisis in the US currently and lactation
service providers and duas have um been
seen to reduce the issue and help um
fill in health
gaps I can take any questions all right
let's see if there are
any no doesn't look like it thank you
farahan good morning I'm fah and I feel
like I need a whiteboard for you all I'm
sorry that I don't have one I love
teaching and it's a little complicated
to do it when you need um some visual
aids and I think that would be really
helpful this morning for
us um dear chairperson Maguire and
members of the House executive
departments and administration committee
my name is Farah Sheen so I'm a
registered nurse I've been a nurse in
New Hampshire for 27 years lots of time
um and I really appreciate this bill the
the overall you know Mom nibus and
assuring that families have access to
duela services and lactation providers
is really essential to address the
maternal morbidity and mortality he
Health crisis that we are experiencing
in our country and in our state I'm in
full support of Medicaid coverage for
duala services and lactation providers
so just out of the gate to be super
clear about that a master's prepared
registered nurse so I'm not quite the
highest level that I can get to in
nursing but up there um and like I said
I've been a registered nurse in New
Hampshire for 27 years I've worked in
hospitals and Community settings all all
the time with moms babies families
perinatal
care and um I currently have my own
practice in New Hampshire as an
independent nurse ibclc and I also
provide Education and Training to
perinatal teams who are grappling with
improving the quality of care so just
wanted to give you a little bit of kind
of my background and where I've been
at um so I'm going to skip over in my
testimony I will I will make sure you
all have copies but um my support for du
Services I think we're all clear on that
it sounds like where the confusion is is
around the lactation so I'll just spend
a couple minutes trying to
clarify
um ibc's are international board
certified lactation Consultants that's
what we've been talking about a little
bit they are generally people who are
already in the health care field nurses
midwives
dietitians and then after some years in
practice they often decide hey I want to
be more skilled in this area I want to
be able to provide um a level of care
that's higher than what I've been
providing we see this a lot in
healthcare right like when people go to
become a nurse practitioner after being
a nurse or um even in medicine they get
you know a
specialty so this is really similar in
in nursing with lactation care and so an
ibclc is an international board
certified lactation consultant who has
many many hours you know has to be
observed for at least a thousand hours
in the
field they have to have at least 90
hours of continuing education above and
beyond just what they would have for
their regular nursing or dietitian or
whatever has to be really specific in
lactation and then they have to sit for
an exam just like you would do if you
were getting any other kind of specialty
in nursing or or
medicine so it's a really um it's a
world-renowned highlevel clinical
practice right it allows me as with my
ibclc to go out into the community and
care for families um with a high level
of skills so I'm not just providing
education and support but I'm actually
assessing for complicated um situations
in lactation and also just in the
overall health and well-being of the
family over the 27 years that I've been
a nurse some of the things that I've
identified in the home when I was going
out there to to look at what was
happening with lactation were other
complex medical issues like seizures um
malnutrition and failure to thrive
heart murmurs you know these types of
things that the skill that I have
allowed me to identify these problems
that hadn't been
identified so it's really important that
people who are out in the community
practicing independently have a high
level of skill to be able to catch um
these more complicated conditions does
that make sense for that
piece certified lactation cons um
counselors which this um not the
original original bill but the amended
that had in those those other um you
know that named the specific
certifications the concern is is that if
we had let if we leave it like that and
we don't adopt the new Amendment from Dr
um from um Senator
Whitley we potentially could have
certified lactation counselors
independently working in the community
or the home setting and with my
experience and credentials and you know
the things that I've seen in in the
world I oppose that I don't think that
that's okay um I don't think it's safe I
don't think it's appropriate I think
it's really good that we have certified
lactation counselors clc's we need them
they're part of the Continuum of Care
they work in our Wick offices ready as
Joyce described it's fully federally
funded that right so we have that level
of care and in fact many of the duelas
who are going to be going out and
providing care for the families under
the nibus under this you know Medicaid
reimbursement will also be clc's lots of
Duos in the community are clc's that's
super appropriate they're certified
lactation counselors they're going to be
providing that basic level of care but
they're not ibclcs they're not providing
that higher skill and so they shouldn't
be billing independently in my opinion
for that
piece um so that's really in a nutshell
you know kind of trying to explain like
the difference and you know my
experience um as a as a professional and
and you know what the potential um you
know how it looks kind of out there in
the world so I'm happy to take any
questions thank you are there any
questions representative Brown and then
luus thank you madam chair um and thanks
for taking my question
did did you say it's important for those
out with independent practice that they
aren't just a CLC did I not quite
understand what you said correct they
shouldn't just be a CLC they should be
an ibclc an international board
certified lactation consult and if
they're going to be practicing
completely independently and billing
under lactation Services I believe with
my years of experience in Education and
Training that that's what they should
have or a or a similar you know high
level now I don't know what what
Medicaid and oplc will decide but that's
definitely my input on that um but clc's
have a place they absolutely need to be
in the system and and they are already
in Wick and um and like I said many duas
who are going to be billing you know
under this bill also are CLC so they
would be you know families are going to
be getting that care we're not taking
anything away from families is my point
by allowing medicate and op oplc to make
the decision on you know really who um
should be um billing independently does
that make sense um you're essentially
saying that the lactation consultant is
a higher level of
professional training and service than
the clc's I am and that and that is the
case if you look at the actual um you
know what's required yeah to to achieve
that for sure okay thank you
represent y just for clarification uh
would you support this bill with the
amendment that we just got from Senator
Whitley absolutely I think it's
appropriate for the oplc to do their due
diligence and make a decision about you
know credentialing I I fully trust um
you know as a registered nurse obviously
I depend on them heavily for my my
licensing so I yeah I think that that's
appropriate thank you okay any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
muler
hello thank you chair McGuire Vice chair
Simon and members of the committee for
the opportunity to testify today my name
is Ellie mul and I am the director of
The Academy of lactation policy and
practice which is the certification body
for the certified lactation counselor
credential um I originally requested
three minutes to speak but I would
really like to address some of the um
misconceptions that have been shared
about our credential I am not an expert
in the ibclc credential nor do I pretend
to be I work for the Academy of
lactation policy and practice and work
directly with clc's um so I'm not going
to sit up here and try and dispute the
difference between the two providers but
some of the information that was shared
with about the CLC credential is
factually inaccurate so I would really
like to correct that with you all today
um and I should start by saying that we
do support the amendment that Senator
Whitley put forward today we're fine
with it being an oplc decision so long
as the language remains open to not pick
one credential in the state of New
Hampshire to be able to become certified
through this pathway um if we're looking
at expansion of the workforce and
increasing access to care we need more
lactation providers not fewer and I
should add that clc's are the largest
group of lactation care providers in New
Hampshire with more than double the
number of ibc's in the state of New
Hampshire do you have actual numbers
yeah I have actual numbers I shared them
with you before today but I'm happy to
share them again via email um I should I
would like to address first that 89.8
again I can share that number with you
89.8% of CLC work in hospital settings
in New Hampshire so you've heard time
and time again already that we're only
in Wick offices and in community offices
factually incorrect I have the numbers
we survey clc's every single uh three
months to make sure that those numbers
are up to date I should also add that
between 8 and 10 I can't remember the
exact number but I will get it between 8
to 10% of clc's are working in private
practice independently in New Hampshire
currently and there have been no cases
of practice concern for public health
harm to the public from those
providers um we've heard also that the
scope of practice of the CLC is not
similar to the ibclc that is also
factually inaccurate in fact if you look
line by line at our scopes of practice
they're almost identical again I'm not
going to sit up here and pretend that I
know the ibclc scope of practice forward
and back but I will add that it is
within the scope of practice of a CLC to
complex to assess and um support and
help to solve complex breastfeeding
issues that occur and also to assess for
those situations and circumstances that
predispose families to challenging
breastfeeding experiences so we are not
just a basic uh lactation educator we
are far more than that and that's uh
really symbolized by the fact that the
Center for Disease Control the CDC and
the United States breastfeeding
committee recogn izes both the ibclc and
the CLC as professional lactation
support providers which was our impetus
to get the CLC included in Senator
Whitley's initial introduction of the
bill um so we were very happy when that
was amended with overwhelming bipartisan
support in the Senate and with the help
of oplc and um dhs's Medicaid director
Henry Litman who I wish was here today
because he is a wonderful person to work
with um I think the bottom line that
I'll wrap up with is to increase access
to lactation care we need more providers
um people could have sat up here and
talked about all of the benefits of
breastfeeding and I'm sure you've heard
it many times through the research
they're vast um and very important we
need to increase access to care and to
allow people the choice to choose a
provider who they feel most comfortable
seeing um in no other field do we say
you can see one type of provider and
that's who you have to pick but if we
know that a provider is going to be
reimbursed by insurance people are going
to pick the provider that's reimbursed
by their insurance company it's it's
obvious um so we really see this as
needing to include more lactation
providers um and I'm just I'm happy to
answer any questions that the committee
may have thank
you thank you I don't see any oh
representing
piart I'm just curious how many
lactation providers do we have what
number are we looking at so again I
don't know the CL the ibclc number off
the top of my head but there's 22 clc's
in the state of New Hampshire and I
believe it was less than half of or
maybe slightly over half of ibclc so 164
165 it's all on their website as well as
it is on ours and just follow up follow
up are some duel certified there are
many people who are clc's and ibc's
together um so you don't know that
though with that 221 number what that I
could look it up and send it to you
absolutely yeah we collect that
information so absolutely okay thank you
any other
questions all right thank you for your
testimony thank you very much is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
337 all right seeing none I will close
hearing and this will be going
committee
that's
embarrassing
e
the hearing on Senate Bill 485 and I
call Senator Carson thank you very much
thank you very much Madam chair and
honorable members of the House Ed Anda
committee for the record my name is
Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of Auburn London
Derry and Hudson and for today for your
consideration I have Senate Bill
485 and this be uh this bill enumerates
the office of professional licensure and
certifications processes and procedures
including issuance of a digit digitally
veriable license certificate or
registration for temporary occupational
license are for military service members
and their
spouses um Madame chair in the fall of
2022 a coalition of military and
Veterans organizations identified
digital occupational licensing as a way
to assist military families facing
Mobility challenges work Mobility
challenges military families are three
times more likely to move than civilian
families and this prevent uh presents a
number of challenges to military working
family and spouses trying to maintain a
professional career approximately 30% of
military spouses maintain a professional
or occupational license a recent US
Department of Defense report found that
about half of military spouses
experiencing a permanent change of
Station Move experience problems with
finding employment and approximately 40%
experience a loss of
income military spouses and Veterans
make up a significant portion of New
Hampshire citizens approximately 10% and
many of these citizens move from state
to state at a higher rate than most
people this means that professional
licensing and the efficient processing
of licenses from state to state is a
major issue for these workers and their
families a digital licensing platform
would create a secure pre pre verified
database that provides the state with
accurate up-to-date information on
individuals licensing status the goal
being to reduce license approval time
from weeks or months to a few days the
process can also be flexible and
customized to the state individual
licenses can be excluded from the
digital licensing process or unique
licensing requirements can be flagged
for individual review and notification
in addition depending on the needs of
the state the prever verification
process can be for can be performed by
an outside vendor or through
collaboration between state agencies and
vendors finally several states have
embraced the use of digital licensing
Kansas and Rhode Island have recently
moved forward with military licens
reciprocity and Virginia's Department of
Professional and occupational regulation
has taken a broader approach by
initiating uh digital licensing for more
than 114 licensing types over 40
professions several years ago New
Hampshire embraced the concept of
licensed Reciprocity for the military
and Senate Bill 485 would be the next
step to ensure the reciprocity process
happens in an efficient and timely way
thank you very much for your time this
morning I really appreciate this and
I think I can probably answer some
questions but um folks are here that
have been really involved in this
process from the very beginning who
could probably answer your questions
much uh I do have a question we recently
changed the military licensing process
to some degree by requiring the Office
of Veterans Affairs to work with
um to get the military codes properly
aligned with licenses and to work with
oplc on that how does this affect that
um thank you for the question and I was
just speaking with representative Brown
um the Senate has House Bill
1385 which speaks to that and in fact
I've been asked to bring in an amendment
I believe representative Brown is
familiar with that that deals with each
military occupational specialty and will
give them the ability to
um to examine each one and come up with
a code through Ru making and I I just
see this as being a partner to that that
once we get through that process then we
can work on assigning the digital part
of it to make it easier but we H I do
believe we need to go through that first
step okay so this bill is effective 6
days if that comment is correct it
year I would like to think it wouldn't
take that long but I'm not sure if 60
days is an appropriate time considering
you've got these two pieces of
legislation moving and that's why I
think that um if someone's here from um
the Veterans Affairs they they're
watching both of these and fig we can
work with them to figure out how to get
them both done in an efficient
time okay any other questions or for
Senator Carson represent blackis uh I
think I saw executive director uh
Courtney come in if that's true I think
the question's probably better for her
okay we will invite executive director
Courtney to speak any other questions
for Senator Carson representative Brown
just thank you madam chair just as a
note in in the amendment that the
senator was speaking to it's what we had
talked about in subcommittee and here
because it's rul making that we're
looking at in 1385 to sort of create
this crosswalk uh we made it January 1st
of
20 six I believe I have to look back at
the amendment but I don't know that that
necessarily means that what they're
trying to do with a digital license
would have to be that same time frame we
can we can uh determine that we can
coordinate I'm sure there will be some
uh overlap
okay the questions for the senator thank
you very much thank you very much Madam
chair and since we already have
Courtney good morning Madam chair
members of the committee Lindsay
Courtney executive director
oplc um so we were following this bill
in the Senate and as originally
introduced it really um dealt primarily
with the digitally verifiable licensed
piece our position was that we don't
take a position because we already have
an electronic platform which I will say
is not the best um but we are migrating
to a new solution and therefore already
verify uh licenses
digitally um that said throughout that
discussion there was conversations about
what are the true barriers for um
military service members and their
spouses um individuals coming out of
military service to seeking a license in
you Hampshire and it's always been that
there isn't a clear pathway from um your
experience in the military your
education experience um to transition to
a license because the two
experiences um while provide the same um
education and experience are not spelled
out in our statutes and rules so we need
to do that
crosswalk the requirement to do the
crosswalk for military service members
has been in 332g since I think
2016 I could be wrong on the dates but
for quite some time um but the boards
haven't taken steps to do the
crosswalks um and so what this would do
is essentially require the oplc to work
with Department of um dmav and um get
the crosswalk done it's very similar to
what's been proposed
um in House Bill 1385 and I think um we
would recommend taking a look and Mar
basically marrying the two to make sure
that they're consistent with each other
um but we are ready willing and able to
work with DMF um to get that done happy
to take any other
questions repr
blackis yeah um I think sort of answered
that and that was how does this interact
with 1385 and what's your view on the
best way to deal with u whatever
interaction there
is so we've we've been working
internally with the Department of
military and Veterans Affairs for the
past year and a half trying to um solve
this issue they have a dedicated staff
member um and we have a dedicated staff
member who um whose project for their
CPM project was um to come up with ways
to provide port ility for military
service members and their spouses the
challenge has been one of authority um
we've seen a few boards kind of push
back on the idea of creating this
crosswalk um and so that's that's where
the barrier lies but I think there are
really only a handful of professions
that we could um determine a an actual
crosswalk to lier in New Hampshire under
the office there are certainly other
crosswalks for other uh license saves to
the office that that could be done as
well and I don't I think it's something
that we can get done in a fairly um
short amount of
time follow up followup so the question
is if well Senate Bill 485 as it's it
currently exists and 1385 as it
currently
exists um is there any problem if both
of these got passed would they help with
the solution I mean what's trying to
figure out what's the best way to help
this along yes so I think they both are
intended to accomplish the same things I
think what we want to do is look at the
language and make sure that um they sink
up with each other so you know 1385
there were some additional modifications
I believe as it currently stands um
there's a proposed modification to 332g
to capture those license types that
don't fall under
oplc um to require those entities those
boards to uh do the crosswalk um if it's
appropriate and I I think that's
something that we would certainly want
to include um if the goal is to make
sure that we're providing Pathways for
military service members and their
spouses who are qualified um so I think
you know I think I don't know if this
would if you're having a subcommittee
but I think this would be something that
we could certainly work on and look at
the proposed amendment 1385 and make
sure that they um they jve with each
other question for the chair uh is this
going to subcommittee and LIC yes and I
think it's going to representative grot
because it appears to be
an organizational issue rather than a
licensing requirements issue we're all
clear on that I won't pursue any more on
this
here okay representative
Simon thank you madam chair maybe more
for representative Brown for 332g
capturing the other boards that don't
fall under oplc we didn't get that
language in did we okay so that would be
something we have to do here and yes if
I could follow up on that follow up that
that is the the uh proposed uh Amendment
that Senator Carson was speaking to adds
that adds that back in as we talked
about in committee here and and the date
was January 1st of 26 I look back
through my emails um I and if I can
follow up just a tiny bit more there
aren't too many really there aren't too
many differences in these there's some
language that we changed based on opl's
preference for how things are said um
but the the the Senate Bill 485 does
have the substantially similar comment
in it that we have been sort of getting
away from I think so okay but they're
they're very it's it's not really much
difference in the two I don't think all
right then I will uh charge the
subcommittee with looking at House Bill
1385 as well and possibly trying to
combine the two bills to make sure there
is no
conflict any other questions for uh
director represent laas on a slightly
different topic uh this is on the
digital
licensing um I mean what is the state of
that you know would it make sense for
that to exist or is it planned to exist
for all licenses whether it's military
people or related people or
not so I think there we need to
understand what is what is meant by
digitally verifiable license um because
the way I interpret it is just we can
verify it digitally um and uh we already
have that capacity
um certainly if there were um there was
a desire for us to have greater
functionality um then that would require
us to go through the traditional
procurement process which is a lengthy
process um something we do all the time
but you know that's that's about a
two-year process from starting the RFP
and um you know awarding a contract
going through governor and Council and
then coming up with an implementation
strategy and you'd also need funding
available so um I don't know if that
answers your question but we already
have electronic verification we do all
of our licensing well I shouldn't say
all we do the large majority of our
licensing online there are some paper
applications but we're in the middle of
a migration to a new platform um the
first set of professions is supposed to
go live sometime in
June just sort of a followup kind of i'
suggest the sub commmittee maybe better
Define what's meant by a digitally
verified license abely unclear to me
thank
you yes all right other questions thank
you very much thank you for your time
Paul
Lloyd good morning Madam chair committee
members my name is Paul Lloyd I'm the
chairman of the state veterans advisory
committee and
we're made up of uh 20 veterans
organizations here in New Hampshire um
and we also have uh four uh state
legislators with us two senators and two
house members uh I'm here today to let
you know that our committee uh fully
Bill thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
with
good morning Madam chair distinguished
members of the committee my name is uh
Scott wiro and I work for a company
called Merit International Incorporated
uh we're a technology company that
provides solutions to State and local
governments uh to include but uh to
include digital licensing verification
um I'm a military spouse of a combat
veteran uh she's had four deployments to
of which uh
where in Afghanistan where I met her
she's a proud UNH grad where she did her
Roc and and received her commission uh
and she's sorry she actually couldn't
make the trip with me here today um so
as a military spouse uh SB 485 is very
close to my heart uh as a military
spouse uh Meritt is part of the Aspire
Coalition uh which stands for the
alliance for States providing
interoperable reciprocity quite a
multiple but is focused specifically on
trying to facilitate the transfer of
licenses for military spouses when they
do a permanent change of station um as
was mentioned earlier this is quite an
issue for military spouses and it can
result in quite a significant loss of
income which disproportionately affects
uh lower ranking members of the military
and so uh we are working within the
coalition to try to provide a solution
to mitigate the effects of those uh
delays in lure and I'm here to provide
uh testimony and support of the bill
that is currently uh before you um the
Aspire Coalition if I could uh is made
up of 11 members uh the association of
the United States Army blue star
families the National military spouse
Network veterans Health and Wellness
Foundation women veterans interactive
Merit International as I mentioned the
military spouse Chamber of Commerce the
military offers Officers Association of
America the US Department of Defense
military spouse employment partnership
the women veterans and families Network
and the Workforce Solutions of Central
Texas so it is a broad Coalition uh that
is all working towards this this same
aim um we work with uh state governments
to build an efficient digital solution
that solves The Last Mile uh of the
licensing reciprocity process by making
the transfer of licenses from one state
to another to another safe secure and
ideally uh
instantaneous uh as I mentioned elat and
transferring licenses have huge
consequences for military families but
by using current state-ofthe-art techn
Tech Solutions uh for combining
licensing
portability legislation with a digital
platform for
interoperability verified credentials
speeds the process and simplifies the
transfer of licenses from one state to
another um as was sort of mentioned if
an active duty service member receives
PCS orders and their spouse is a nurse
the spouse would want to quickly find
employment when they moved uh to their
new state to do so they would need to
get a copy of their nursing license from
the originating State and share it with
the new state however they may encounter
challenges and delays receiving and
sharing a copy of the license and once
shared the plausible different
requirements between states could cause
the spouse to need additional training
furthering the time of
relicensure add to that the fact that
each state has a different process that
the military spouses must navigate every
time that they move
with an effective digital solution
licensing portability requirements
between states would be clearly mapped
and communicated to military spouses and
Veterans guiding them through the
process of verifying their license when
PCS orders are received military spouses
would access their Merit app on their
mobile device select their originating
State and the state that they're
transferring to then the license or
certifications they hold the app would
display all of the steps necessary and
document ation required for transferring
their license the license holder could
also upload any required documentation
such as military orders discharge orders
or a marriage
certificate we hope that this would then
put the spouse in a position where they
no long longer feel left in the dark
during this process as the app tracks
ontime status of the license and
documentation as they're verified the
moment reciprocity is granted the
license holder would receive a digital
version of their license through the app
along with a Q QR code that potential
employers can use for instant license
verification licens spouses veterans and
family members can get back to work
weeks or months faster every time they
must move saving unemployment costs and
helping bolster local economy through
income and
tax um in Illinois this this process
currently takes two to three months for
healthcare workers uh to attain their
license it state government is currently
in the process of uh solving this
problem working very close with them on
that um the Pennsylvania Board of
Nursing for example takes 12 weeks uh
for its State's nurses to receive
licenses more than half of the 12,000
nurses who are issued licenses in 2021
LED waited at least three months
according to a recent report milit
military spouses on average wait 42 days
to be relicensed which on average is a
loss of income totaling approximately
$5,000 for low ranking military members
as I mentioned and their families this
has an enormous impact on their
household income and quality of life
your support for sb45 is a tribute to
military spouses and to all those
serving our nation today and in the
years to come New Hampshire has a unique
opportunity to quickly Implement digital
licensing re reciprocity legislation
Drive Community economic growth and most
importantly improve the lives of
military families who call the granted
State their home thank you for allowing
me the opportunity to address this
committee I'm Happ happy to address any
questions you may
have thank you it sounds like you ought
to be pitching your system to the oplc
if they'd be the ones who'd have to buy
it we're certainly not going to mandate
them buy it any other questions comments
representative Brown uh thank you again
Madam chair uh for clarification can uh
two things uh uh the Merit International
is that that's who you work for did I
miss that yes sir I an employee of
national the Aspire Coalition as
ASP sir thank
you okay thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
Perry Madam chair members of the
committee Warren Perry Deputy agitant
general for the Department of military
Affairs and veteran services just to
would offer that the department
wholeheartedly supports Senate Bill 485
and because of the advantages it gives
for the portability of licenses for
military spouses as they transition into
New Hampshire and I'll leave it at that
pending any questions
uh no I but I think we will ask you to
work with the subcommittee
because uh I know you supported House
Bill 1385 we want to make sure we
don't uh lose anything in the
combination it would be my pleasure
Madam chair very good you other
testimony okay does anyone else wish to
testify on Senate Bill
485 all right seeing none I will close
the public hearing and our next one is
at
11:15
e
it's 11:15 so I'm going to open the
public hearing on Senate Bill 488 and
welcome representative Maguire to
introduce the
bill uh good morning morning Mr chair
members of the committee I'm Carol
Maguire marac District
27 and this bill is simply to fix
some minor issues with the regulation of
physician assistance that were noticed
when we're doing one of our many other
bills on the topic uh it exempts
physician assistance from needing a
barbering or cosme ology license if they
have to say shave the hair off your arm
before doing
surgery which which is actually covered
under under cosmetology and other
professionals are Exempted so we want
physician assistance to be Exempted
also and the other is to clarify the
continuing education requirements which
may need further
education and um
well I
will try to um answer any questions but
that's about all I know about this
bill any questions yes representative
leas it's the one I I kind of brought up
offline and that is there is something
under definitions on requirements for
continuing education that lists a number
of options I don't think they're
identical to what's in this bill and
probably we need to look at those to
figure out
that strikes me as duplic something the
reason to send this bill to your
subcommittee to clarify what the current
requirements are
because uh as I recall they aren't very
well defined yeah there's a list but
nowhere does it in definitions but
nowhere does it say you have to meet
them it's like it's this H hanging thing
we can look at it subcommittee well
that's
uh exactly the kind of thing
subcommittees are needing needed to work
on I will not say that this bill is
better than what's current currently in
statute it's trying to be
more expansive and that's about
it any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much Grant I can never remember if it's
bossy thank you representative sorry
slightly late Senator Pearl asked me to
pinch hit on very short notice he got
called
away um good morning members of the
committee I'm Grant bossy here to
introduce Senate Bill 488 on behalf of
Senator Pearl the prime sponsor uh this
bill cleans up two separate and
unrelated regulatory items concerning
physician assistance section one
authorizes oplc and the Board of
Medicine to maintain continuing medical
education records for Pas who choose not
to maintain their accreditation section
two corrects the omission of physician
assistance from the exemptions under RSA
313 a25 in line with the dozen other
categories of healthcare providers
Exempted from the barbering cosmetology
and Aesthetics license this was simply
an oversight uh Senator Pearl has worked
with oplc and the PAs to craft this
legislation which received unanimous
support in the Senate if you have
questions I'll make sure Senator PE gets
you an answer he thanks you for
consideration and support of Senate Bill
488 thank you great thank you any
questions
seeing done thank you very much for your
you good morning uh I'd say Madam chair
although I see she's behind me um and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Sarah Lesley I'm a licensed
PA in New Hampshire and I live in
Deerfield I'm the vice president of the
New Hampshire Society PA as well as the
co-chair for our society's legislative
committee uh as not Senator Pearl noted
this bill would clean up two unrelated
issues pertinent to PA regulations and
the first deals with continuing medical
education recordkeeping uh when we
passed SP uh 228 two years ago we had a
little oversight whenever it went to the
Board of Medicine it was pointed out to
us um that we took out of Statute that a
PA needs to maintain their nccpa
certification out of Statute which
brought us in line with the majority of
the other states in the US um but we
didn't give the Board of Medicine the
power to delegate to oplc the ability to
um maintain our CME for those Pas those
very few Pas that don't maintain their
nccpa
certification um so specifically s488
gives oplc and the Board of Medicine the
ability to maintain CMEs for Pas who
choose not to maintain their
certification it's very like I said it's
very few Pas that would do that um most
of us are employers require that we
maintain our nccpa certification but say
a retired pa um that doesn't want to sit
for a high stakes exam but wants to
maintain their license um those are kind
of the the small Niche group that it
would apply to um and then the Pas who
maintain their nccpa certification of
course our 100 CME is followed by the
nccpa we have to do that every two years
in order to maintain our CT and then of
course sit for the high high stakes exam
every uh 10 years state law does not
require that Pas maintain our
certification through the nccpa but we
must maintain our CME so this fix simply
gives oplc the ability to maintain the
CME for those Pas and the second Bill
corrects just an Omission we spent a lot
of time looking through statute and
regulations finding where our name is
either written in correctly or we're
just not in there um we find a lot of
places where Physicians nurse
practitioners are listed but we just
inadvertently are not so this um
unfortunately these fixes are simple but
they require legislation um currently
law exempts many healthare providers
from needing a barbering cosmetology and
Aesthetics license due to that oversight
with the Pas were not given the same
exception as our doctors nurses and
other
practitioners this bill simply exempts
Pas from needing this license both parts
of this bill were drafted in cooperation
with oplc um and if you have any
questions I'm happy to take them thank
you for your testimony any
questions uh yes representative
Brown uh thank you Mr
chair in the in the bill there's the
word requirements continuing medic
medical education requirements and
everyone keeps saying recordkeeping and
law I don't know that it's clear that
it's recordkeeping um can you clarify
that for me in any
way have the actual law in front of you
can I steal that the actual stat yeah
well not the okay that's the bill itself
yes um so record keeping so basic
basically with it it's just delegating
the power to the Board of Medicine to or
giving the power to the Board of
Medicine to then allow oplc to maintain
our our CME
um so let me see what it actually says
and I apologize as a followup yeah
that's what I understood but it says
requirements which wouldn't mean the
same thing to me necessarily so what
what would happen then the Board of
Medicine would then decide what our CME
requirements would be which when we had
chatted with them we said about just
keeping the same that we have with the
CCPA which would be 100 um total CME
every 2 years and 50 of those need to be
category one which are certificate based
um continued medical medical education
credits so the Board of Medicine would
then decide what um what those CME would
be and then the oplc would then track it
for us as they are doing for
Physicians any other
questions seeing done thank you very
much for your testimony okay did anybody
488 seeing n I'll close the public
hearing on S SP 488 I'll refer the bill
to the licensing subcommittee and uh we
are off until 1:15 and enjoy the next
two
hours
e
at being 1115 I'm going to open the
public hearing on S SP 369 and welcome
Grant
thank
you
thanks thanks good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee uh Grant bosi
Deputy Chief of Staff for the New
Hampshire Senate here to introduce
Senate Bill 369 on behalf of Senator
Carson the Bill's Prime sponsor I'll be
with you for most of the afternoon uh
this bill adds Provisions for public
notice and public comment for boards
under the office of professional
licensure and certification over the
years these many disperate boards have
widely varying policies and levels of
compliance with New Hampshire's op
meetings law sp sp 369 would establish a
baseline of 14 days for meetings to be
publicly noticed with exemptions for
emergencies and flexibility for late
agenda items
it also ensures that state boards will
provide the opportunity for public
comment similar to guarantees this
legislature has recently passed for
municipal meeetings the bill is similar
to a bill vetoed by the governor but
Senator Carson believes the changes
address his concerns sp sp 369 also
establishes a new attorney position with
oplc to ensure it has the capacity to
comply with the public notice
requirements the fiscal impact would be
$106,000 in
fy2 SB 369 has twice received receive
the unanimous support of the Senate I
would defer questions to the subject
matter experts here today if you have
any questions they can't answer I will
make sure Senator Carson gets you an
answer Senator Carson thanks you for
your consideration and support of SP 369
rart
good morning committee Mr chairman uh my
name is Steve rort I'm here representing
the electrical contractors Business
Association and licensed electricians um
we are in favor and support of this bill
we we tried to worked to get this
through last year as I mentioned and it
just had a couple issues and concerns
the governor had and I think we've
worked through it it's there's a lot of
hearings that are had just monthly um
meetings for boards and stuff and
everything and it's very tough for us to
as a public to be part of it when they
only have 24 hours notice so technically
they like for example they have a
meeting once a month for the
electricians board and it might be
scheduled on on there for April 5th and
they don't if it's not going to be till
April 9th they don't have to post it
till April 8th so many times I've come
up here and it's been canceled or change
and you and you've wasted a lot of time
and I've lost a lot of money to come be
part of it and it happens with all of
them in the rules hearings and stuff so
this gives a couple weeks notice at
least the boards and the oplc the
ability if there's an emergency to add
it to the agenda it's not trying to make
it so tough that they can't do that just
giving some notification for these
meetings so that people from the public
can be part of especially with all the
changes that's going on with OPC and all
the bills out there it's really hard to
keep track of so how's that under two
minutes perfect well done any questions
Greta are you familiar with the concerns
that the governor had and what how were
they addressed in this bill believe the
concerns were if was an emergency
meeting let me just look at the uh
and if there was the ability to have
that meeting and add something to the
agenda within 48 hours if the the the
chairman of the board feels that the
urgency of the issue overrides the
public notification and I believe that
they give seven calendar days I believe
they also Dro on line 11 um the chair of
the board of counsel shall I Adam s
within seven calendar days of the
meeting at the chair's discretion and it
continues to go on to just discuss what
that is what they would use to to to
meet that um those I think were the two
things was not having um the ability to
add something in emergency like for a
situation we had the massachusett
electrican would stop um reciprocity
with in Hampshire for electrical and we
only found out about it a day before the
board meeting something like that was
very important to respond to so gives
them the ability to add that so I think
those two things were the biggest
concerns
what
and you may not be able to answer this
but was there an appropriation for an
additional head count in the in the bill
that Governor the governor vetto
originally I believe there was an
appropriation yes okay thank you y and
fiscal any other questions seeing none
thank you very much thank
hop
good afternoon Douglas Hoster out oplc I
should be really brief um I can also
answer questions if you have questions
about the bills and sort of the
governor's position is as much as I'm
aware of it um I did send around a
proposed amendment yesterday to the
chair the vice chair and the clerk I
don't know in some written testimony um
just I think there might be a mistake in
the language uh I pointed out a comma I
don't believe needs to exist on line
five and page one but the bigger issue
is there's a part of a sentence in the
proposed seven and eight
area that would keep the record open for
seven days and the way I read this it's
open for seven days for the public the
spoken comment I believe that was
intended to be keep the record open for
the written comment so I just the
amendment basically switches those
around um I don't know everybody's had a
uh yes representative was that emailed
to the committee it was emailed to the
chair Vice chair and clerk I saw it yeah
okay uh should I send it to the
committee or is
that okay I'll do that today um but
other than that um I didn't have any
questions um I just I just have one just
out of curiosity I know that it's coming
out of the uh Office Professional lure
and certification fund but you guys need
a full-fledged lawyer to post meetings I
think so
because it's it's sort of similar we've
had discussions on like the 1527
language 1622 it's the same idea there
could be confidential information so
everything that we post we want to post
timely and that has to undergo uh some
sort of legal review in order to make
sure we're not you know putting out home
home addresses uh phone numbers those
kind of things or whatever information
wouldn't normally be subject to
disclosure under
much would anybody else like to testify
369 seeing none I will close the public
hearing and we will reconvene in 35
committee
e
so I I uh we do have a forum
so we'd like to discuss Senate Bill
certifications
yes
okay AR right everybody on the same page
represent
blackis yeah I guess you need a motion
to start things out um I'll move to
adopt Amendment 1386
s okay I'll
second you wish to speak to your motion
I do um you know there's a lot of
discussion we heard
about which outfits should handle the
certification and all that but what this
will do uh with the amendment is let
that be hashed out during rule making um
with oplc and everybody who has an
interest in their view on it should have
an opportunity to be involved in yes
BR nothing to add thank you okay i' I'd
like to mention that this is a an early
Bill and it is going on to
another another committee which I think
is Health and Human
Services um oh the financial numbers are
probably going to be
sure ah fine we will approve the intent
and worry about the
detail not supposed to do that first
Carol uh chair yes as people people have
been mentioning this is a senate
amendment can we do this we can't use
that we can't do that we will need to
get a house
amendment can we execute like this or no
can we have the executive session
contingent on representative lucus going
to Ops and getting the amendment under
his name
or I go do it now we could yeah a second
thought why don't we not vote on this
until after we get the amendment it
sound like it would
be it sound like that would be a uh an
exercise all right
Tony I got I have to go over anyway you
want me to
do
okay all right any in that case take
need
e
lighten I'm opening the hearing on
Senate Bill 371 is there somebody here
it
good afternoon chairperson Maguire and
members of the committee my name is
Jennifer Gallagher and I'm the executive
assistant to the Senate minority office
with your Indulgence I will be in
introducing Senate Bill 3 371 on Senator
Fenton's behalf and I'll be reading it
directly into the record as written by
him I am state senator Donovan Fenton
and I represent district 10
chesher Medical Center in Keen is in my
district and the training place to
training Physicians for several sessions
in collaboration with the office of
professional Li lure and
certification this committee and house
Edna has worked hard to streamline
licensing processes this work has
ensured timely access to lure and
gainful employment in New Hampshire
thank you last year House Bill 655
created a lot of efficiencies within
oplc one of those was moving all license
renewals to every 2 years this is
largely celebrated however there is one
group that now has some concerns about
the 2-year requirement and that is
resident
Physicians currently the Board of
Medicine is working with hospitals to
license their forthcoming resident
Physicians oplc is working toward an
online system which I believe will be
live by June 30th of this year our
resident Physicians are concerned about
their ability to support the LI lure of
these residents this bill would allow
the board to work with oplc to allow for
licenses that are slightly longer than 2
years removing the requirement that a
resident physician renew their license
in the middle of their
residency this bill will positively
impact Dartmouth Hitchcock and other
hospitals including Dairy Medical and
conquered
hospital I believe Dartmouth health is
here to provide more detail and to
answer any questions you may have thank
you for your consideration to ensure we
pipelines thank you are there any
questions seeing none and we we would
appreciate the hard a copy of your uh
files
courtt Courtney
[Music]
Tanner I said morning but it's certainly
not that anymore good afternoon Courtney
Tanner for the record I'm the senior
director of government relations at
Dartmouth Health um here to support
Senate Bill 371 very grateful for uh
that Senator Fenton brought this forward
um we really as you know um are
experiencing Workforce constraints on
similar to all sectors in our economy um
and really see this as one piece of the
pie that will help us to ensure LIC
insure for a critical component of our
Workforce at the at the medical center
so these are resident Physicians um who
are with us usually on average between
three to four years um and right now um
we are creating lensy packets that go to
the Board of Medicine um in our process
for their for their time that they're
with us for their residency
um and uh they don't have to reapply for
a license every single year um I want to
uncore that we appreciate all the work
that oplc and this committee has done to
streamline licensing processes for other
types of licenses this is just a little
bit of a niche area and we again are
very grateful to Senator Fenton for
bringing this forward and are hopeful
that um that this committee will support
it so if I understand correctly
residents Physicians are liced Ed as
Physicians they are they are okay do you
think it is that much of a hardship for
them to figure out after two years they
have to apply for a renewal so um it's
something that our medical staff office
actually handles and supports and so um
it's really done in concert with our gme
office our graduate Medical Education
Office uh and it's something that we do
support them with because they're
working extremely long hours um they're
working beyond the 40-hour work week
like the like most um so it is something
that we support them to
do okay that's interesting anyone else
representative Brown thank you madam
chair um in in the law and this may be
not relevant to the wording in the bill
but in the law it says that the board
chillis Who special training
licenses uh Etc in a regular residency
or graduate Fellowship training program
so so would it make sense that this
should say a residency training license
or does it not need to say that because
it references the
law um well actually I believe that oplc
uh I Doug may be testifying after
actually has an amendment to this that
is a slight change in verbiage so that
may address your question thank
you
okay
Tony um how long what's the longest that
somebody might be a resident and need
this license sure
um so the longest that a residency would
go to is up to S years if you're a
surgical resident um but usually on
average our residents are wor us three
to four
else guess I'm going to go back to
representative Maguire I mean sorry
chair McGuire's question
about the hardship because I
I'd like a more concrete answer if
possible sure uh so we so like I said we
support um we support these licenses in
their application process and so this
helps us to ensure that we as an
institution
um uh so for doctors they have to be
licensed and then have to be credential
and privileged and these this subset is
also supervised and so um this our
support our administrative support of
the license as one component to ensuring
that this Workforce can be actively
practicing at the at our Medical Center
and so um we this has to go through our
graduate medication office and so we
it's not so much of a hardship for the
physician themselves for our medical
staffing
office don't doctors have to have their
licenses renewed every two years as well
yes they do so follow
up so I I guess are you saying that The
Graduate Office is the one that's
burdened while your medical office is
not who who who you know renews the
doctor's licenses so I actually would
have to get back to you on that that
question um this is again this is a
subset that I've been working with our
medical staff office because this has
been this will be a significant change
that will happen um when the online
okay represent Simon Madam chair I'll
feel silly if I don't understand this
correctly
um is the bill trying to
accomplish uh not having these people
have to renew their licenses every two
years so they get to go longer than that
before they have to renew license or
they don't have to renew license or so
status quo right now the Board of
Medicine is approving resident physician
licenses for the length of time that
they're going to be being in their
resident so um right now what ha status
quo what happens before this online
system is stood up um uh Family Practice
resident physician would come through
our graduate medic medic gme office
graduate medical education and um apply
for a three-year residency so Jane Smith
her packet would go to the board of
medicine for a three-year license um a
surgical resident would go for longer
than that um but they're approved by the
Board of Medicine for the length of
their residency the projected length of
their residency this change in statute
that requires every two-year renewal is
a change to to the status quo and we're
looking for Ru making Authority um or
for oplc to have rulemaking authority to
create a structure that would um allow
for some
flexibilities from the twoe you know
deviate from the two-year
requirement um follow follow um so
I'm confused as to how the bill is
written would accomplish that um it
references two rsas the first RSA deals
with training licenses that expire any
year and continues to say that in the
same paragraph in fact the paragraph two
I believe in statute is the same here as
it is there with the exception that
we've added this one clause in and then
unless I'm mistaken and once again these
are all things that I'll feel really
silly if I'm wrong on but RSA
32992 that's referenced doesn't exist
yeah 22 sorry doesn't exist um so there
is an amendment that um Doug from your
cover it Doug Mr asra I apologize okay
very good all right other questions so
I'm not crazy you're not crazy thank
you all right I don't see any more
Deck good afternoon Douglas Hout PLC um
I did receive the office doesn't take a
position on this bill either way um but
I did receive a copy of an amendment the
executive director and Miss Tanner work
together um Lindsay and I had a
conversation yesterday so that if the
committee decides to move forward we
would Rectify those kinds of things
because I also found problems with sort
of the bill as proposed uh I like I said
I just got a copy of it this morning um
I will share that with the committee as
soon as I leave here today uh I do have
one paper copy wasn't intending to share
but basically it removes those statutory
requirements representative Brown to
your question earlier about
find um I I believe that just the
reference to the license type is enough
and that's that's sort of what we did in
the amendment I'll share that around and
then the the second part which
referenced uh RSA 3299 We just cleaned
it up so everything should be consistent
with 310 1095 that we're doing this year
uh that's my hope with this amendment um
and because I got it late I haven't had
a chance to share it yet okay
so is it your understanding that a
resident physician resident is different
than than a physician
license other than the
term that's what I'm
and do they have stat is there statutory
license because if there isn't we need
to fix that that's an excellent question
because if there isn't one then I don't
know how they would even be subject to
okay representative Simon thank you
madam chair yeah I mean that was I think
the one of the points I was trying to
drive at is neither of these well the
one doesn't exist at all anyway 22
doesn't it's not in statute um so it's
not referencing anything that I can see
and then 32914 just deals with training
licenses as far as I can see it doesn't
have anything to do with residency
licenses it says training licenses for
people who are in residency but that's
as far as it goes so I was I was unable
to reconcile that are those terms
interchangeable I suppose is the
question I'd have to take a look at the
language in more detail and if I'll
follow up you follow up and if it is the
training licenses are set for one year
to expire every one year as they still
are in this in the bill that we have in
anyway line five and those apprentices
licensed for one year in accordance with
rules adopted and that's the way it is
statute so that that that language for
the one year in accordance with rules
that was language that was originally
meant to apply I believe to electrician
apprentice licenses yeah this is a
modification of that but that was a
reference to the electrician apprentices
that one year right these are not
Apprentice doctors no but if you go to
the RSA that it's referencing
32914 I believe you'll see that it says
temporary or training licenses for
people in residency and apprentices for
one
year once again I don't know I'm maybe
I'm the only one who's on this Trail but
oh no I I
yes oh follow up on
that brown under
32914 5 C it says training licenses
shall be confined to activities
performed in the course of the
qualifying residency shall expire
automatically upon the licy separation
from The Residency so that makes it as
long as
necessary
right until you're done with your
residency if I I mean for two years
except for residency licenses
[Music]
okay
5c that's referenced in the bill at the
end and under 5A is where it says the
board shall issue special training
licenses in a regular residency or
program so correct me if I'm wrong
again it looks like it you have your
training your residency training license
that will continue until you're done
residency so it sounds like this bill is
not actually
needed except for the fact that the the
310 has a not withstanding any the other
section of law
right
right right so this one is uh yeah oh
that's right so so basically this is
a it's implementing
those that license and
saying it can be for for any duration up
residency and did we look at
3299 3299 is that applicable as
well um
Roman um oh sorry rep represent six
specifically says they can license is
limited to specific periods of time
residency so is it correct to say that
the main thing this bill wants to do is
to eliminate the overreaching except two
two
years uh regardless of any other statute
law is that correct that's my
understanding of it right so right
because under 310a all of the licensing
terms R PLC became two years except for
these apprentices license with the with
the car rout that exists now and this
would be an additional car rout so that
in rule we could establish the license
to be the duration of The Residency not
necessarily two
years
or yes can someone can you confirm that
we do have a RSA 329 colon9 section 22
because if we do it's not and I know
this has happened
before so
um we just need to know what that is
it's
329 ah it's
new and
in uhuh so that's Ru making
Authority okay correct correct it is Ru
making Authority that's what 3299 is and
it ends at at 21 so this is a new
22 so it just adds this to to it adds
residencies to the long list of things
that are people that are already allowed
under Ru making under the statute right
okay all right now now we understand now
we can question whether we need this
representative like us
so um the amendment you're talking about
would it just change section or Roman 2
section one Roman 2 and if
so what would it say it's very short you
want me to just read it sure okay uh so
section two would read licenses shall be
valid for two years from the date of
issuance except for physician residency
licenses and Apprentice licenses the
duration of physician residency license
and Apprentice licenses shall be
established by the office in accordance
with 541a timely and complete
application for license renewal by
eligible applicants shall continue the
validity of the license being renewed
until the office has acted on the renal
application and then the second piece
changes the sentence to remove the and
duration so the eligibility requirements
for phys residencies under RSA 329 colon
14 hard
stop
followup okay so we have to look at the
language look at it closer but it seems
like it's taking the one year out so
leaving that up to Ru making for The
Apprentice licenses which you said were
electricians correct
um and again I'd have to follow yeah I I
agree how does who sets the duration of
of the resident license and
well Madam chair yes C of Physicians and
surgeons and it says the board shall so
it must be the medical board I'm
guessing that there is some hold over
language that 1095 is intending to clean
up that would right there's places all
over statute where it says the board
issues the license Etc so that's what
our our bill is trying to
do on the other side clean up those
conflicts right so the existing
language but
um
does your Amendment address the rule the
rules for duration of licenses because
it'll be established in
rule you better have rule then you
better have rule making authority to do
that and that's what this amendment
would give us
or we have it for the processes this
would
clarify black us I think you're getting
another another simple Little Bill with
no
problem the simplest things are
complicated I I think when you see the
language I mean depending on the policy
decision but it'll be kind of clear what
we did with the amendment okay so if I
can if any if any of you hear me say
something wrong to recap the board has
the authority to licence residents as
residents for for as long as they want
the
oplc is taking over the licensing
responsibility and will'll have rules
about it and this this exempts them from
the
two-year renewal process is that is that
essentially what you're intending to do
I not me well but yeah I believe that's
the intent of the bill um I do want to
clarify the office already has the
ability to issue the license the board
is setting that criteria that was a 6x5
change right right right so right the
the off the board sets the
criteria the oplc issues the license and
we need this to exempt them from the two
years regardless okay thank you I think
that's give them the ru making Authority
right
okay all right just is briefly if you if
you can when you have the the language
yes sent it out and also take a look if
there's any conflict with 1095 or we'll
do that I got the language late this
morning so I just didn't have an
opportunity to share it but I'll do that
as soon as I get back all right thank
you and I expect we'll see you for the
licensing
subcommittee all right any further
questions for Mr
aerous all
right thank you very much for your
explanations and your amendments and uh
is there anyone else who wishes to
306 no sorry we're not on 306 we're
still on two
371 don't see anybody so I will close
the hearing we
[Music]
what
e
all right I want to warn the committee
this is another short simple
all right and I'm opening the hearing on
Senate Bill
you madam chair members of the committee
uh if you want to skip this just go out
the pass Senator rard would be fine with
that um my name is Grant bosy pleased to
be back before you here to introduce
Senate Bill 369 uh 306 excuse me on
behalf of Senator avard the prime
sponsor s SP 306 shifts rulemaking
Authority for dispute resolution within
the board of manufactured housing from
the installation Standards Board to the
office of professional lure and
certification bringing the process in
line with recent statutory changes in
into compliance with the Federal
Department of Housing and Urban
Development last session the legislature
transferred rulemaking over disciplinary
and non-disciplinary procedures in oplc
in both HB 655 and HB 409 sb36 is
consistent with this policy the bill
does not repeal the installation
Standards Board it just moves oplc in
charge of drafting rules on manufactured
housing dispute resolution along with
its current similar duties I will defer
questions to director Courtney and her
staff if there are questions they can't
answer which is rarely the case I'll
make sure Senator avard gets you an
answer Senator avard thanks you for your
consideration and support of sp36 thank
you uh actually I I have one question
that I hope you might be able to at
least give us a clue to what kind of
manufactured housing disputes are you
talking about that are other than
complaints and
investigations against the people doing
the
installations
because if you're talking
about infr Park issues that's not
something I want to stick to the oplc
with I don't know I was asked to uh
introduce this bill a couple hours ago
and I am happy to pinch hit but I'll
have to take that pitch I'll make sure
to get you an answer thank you because
that's I'm not sure what he's what
exactly he's talking
about thank you for your testimony other
questions to be relay to senator aard
all right thank you thank you for your
house good afternoon Douglas ster help
for OPC we don't take a position on this
uh to answer your question this is
separate from the complaint process the
history as far as I know or understand
it is it's supposed to be an alternative
a lowcost alternative to having to file
something in court
I think it's sort of a hold over from
before they were with the
oplc that's that's but what kind of
they legal disputes I don't know the
answer to that question okay because
that that's the whole point if
it's if it's a question of somebody
saying they Pro inspect installed my
manufactured house and it leaks I would
think that would be a
complaint or would that be a dispute
does anybody does anybody represent
goalie thank you madam chair I'm as I
look at what's being repealed uh RSA 205
D20 uh
11 um that clarifies what it is so I'm
not sure we really want to repeal that
or we maybe want to clarify what
resolution means because um 11 says the
establishment of a program for the
timely resolution of disputes between
manufacturers retailers and installers
of manufactured housing regarding
responsibility for the issuance of
appropriate orders and for the
correction or repair of defects in
manufactured houses that are reported
during the one-year period following the
date of installation so we may want to
have that somewhere in statute so we
know what we're the dispute is we're
resolving here ah and I'm not sure where
we want to put
it so this is if somebody says my H my
house leags and the person and the
installer says that's the way it came
from the factory this deals with with
that issue that's what it appears on 11
the way I read it and if we repeal that
then there's really no definition of
what the resolution is in
statute thank
you and I'll defer to the attorney on
whether or not I think that's a really
good point like what is this supposed to
be addressing if we remove that
definition so so my understanding of it
in the impetus of this bill is that it's
just not happening the rules expired I
in April of
2022 the board has not to throw anybody
under the bus but been dragging their
feet on this there's also a question
about whether because it's a process if
it should even be with the board or
whether it should fall with the oplc we
um were given rule making Authority on
disciplinary proceedings
non-disciplinary proceedings last year
so to I think I think the executive
directors of the opinion we may already
have the statutory Authority I don't
know if I agree with her on that because
I don't think it's entirely clear from
the language so this would would clarify
that the oplc would have that rulemaking
Authority uh we would have to find a
location I think to figure out what this
is supposed to be doing now the other
the other piece to not having this in
place is that there's a a federal
default so if the state doesn't have
rules we're using the federal process
which is what we have now I'm not
entirely familiar with that process but
anecdotally I'm told it's terrible and
nobody likes it so we want our own State
process back in just back in the game um
the board did file a fiscal impact
statement back in January but they have
not filed an initial proposal yet and I
don't think they meet again until June
13th
so just putting that out there um we'd
be happy to take it on if you think
that's the best decision with a smile
and um but we don't take a
position thank you representative go
goie did you have something to add just
want I want to follow up that I agree if
we don't at least have some sort of
definition what a resolution is or this
wording put back in somewhere that then
there's an issue okay represent
G because this all these issues are sort
of tangled up in my mind I'm trying to
last year we had a bill to discuss
manufactured
housing was it and that we we repeal
that in House Bill too correct no
separate boards there's manufactured
housing and there's the installation
board it's very confusing and what
happened to the housing board that's
gone what I'm talking about is the
installation Standards Board corre
correct okay so that other board which
was the one that was I think the one
that we were talking about within a
park that board is gone so we've already
decided we're not going to we're not
part of that so this is more like a
technical board is that what you're
saying this board deals with the
inspection and certification of
manufactured housing standards that is
did they install it correctly on the
right kind of
Foundations and there's dis this allows
for disputes with the manufacturer
retailers and installers which may or
may not be triggered by a complaint okay
I think I've been enlightened on this so
apparently we
accidentally repealed the dispute
resolution
board which is required by Hud
and I remember this
conversation this is I remember that
conversation and we need in order if we
don't have this board then our program
is no longer in compliance with the
federal program I mean this is this is
starting to ring a bell and I think we
need to in order for that to happen
that's what this bill does it fixes that
repeal that we shouldn't have had but I
agree that we shouldn't repeal the rest
of it either because that's what that's
where all the
information is defines
responsibility installation standard
board is still a board that exists in
meets they have a meeting scheduled for
June 13th yeah so what we what we need
to avoid the HUD process is our own
State
process not necessarily a
border and the the
note the description of the bill says
they're repe repealing the fees but
that's only Roman 7 Roman 10 and
are are not the fee 10 is hearing how to
conduct hearings which I think all all
see already has but the program for
dispute resolution is not in um not
anywhere else as far as I know so I just
want to make sure I'm sorry excuse me
please follow up first sorry um so I
just want to make sure what you're
saying is if we have have our own State
program we don't need the HUD program we
default out of it correct and whose
decision I mean what whose policy
decision is that oh it's in the cfrs I
don't have that reference right in front
of me but it it says if you don't have
a if the states have their own process
then they don't have to follow the HUD
process that's that's our
decision that's the policy
decision pleas finish R bro and then rep
so I just want to make sure that if we
pass this bill we're agreeing that we
don't want want to be part of the HUD
process but if we do want to be part of
process do I have it backwards I think
if you
want if you if we pass this bill we're
we're providing an alternative to the
HUD process if we kill it there doesn't
appear to be one okay correct then it's
important that we pass
I mean technically we still need to
build
out yes I was just going to point out
this what we're looking at is an amended
version the original Senate Bill 306 the
title was reinstating the board of
manufactured
housing ah which apparently this we
didn't want the Senate didn't want
so okay so so this is reinstating a
small piece of board of manufactured
housing under the office okay
right excuse me
representative Mr bossy you have
a please uh I think we need to hear
if
so just to provide a little bit of
background the decision on the uh the
underlying board that was a subject of
the introduced bill has been
controversial Senators have disagreed on
this Senator rard was not on the
prevailing side of last year's Bill he
brought in a bill to try to undo that
decision he could not count to 13 and
decided to use this bill for another
amendment
okay thank
you represent black
us
so as I've heard more in reading through
it and this I'm going to ask Doug if he
agrees so it is sort of a question um
I'm thinking the bill as it stands might
be
okay because what it's getting rid of in
D20 is yeah there's
the the fees which is fine uh procedure
for conducting
hearings which is fine and then the main
one is 11 which is the establishment of
a program for timely resolution of
um that's the one that gets into what
the disputes could and actually I may
just decide what I just said was wrong
about it being fine as it is I mean we
might need to
take something like 11 ex Roman XI and
and put it in the bill somehow to
indicate what kind of
complaints we want oplc to deal with so
that might be the way to do
it okay
Simon thank you madam chair
um speaking to
205d uh 2011 uh the establishment of a
program for timely resolution of
disputes does that exist did they create
that would be the manufactured that
expired in it wasn't Rule and it expired
in April of 2022 of 2022 okay so we have
nothing is what okay we have that was
what the HUD process yes that form of
process I any other questions comments
concerns all
right representative Brown thank you
madam chair someone helped me out here
normally on the amendment if the initial
bill is just being done away with it
says that somewhere in the amendment
doesn't say that no not always no okay
thank
you we only see what's left after the uh
after the amendment has taken
place yes and it never changes the
sponsors which is why you're going to
see our representative Gallagher
presenting sponsoring a bill to
uh rewrite oplc
essentially yes
Simon thank you again so this is where
my brain was going I just didn't know
yet so um they expired in 2022 April
2022 why did they not renew
it we don't
know great question I'll have to take it
back and ask a member of the
board I don't know I know they I mean
they have been
I can say they have been working on
rules on this but I feel like I could
have been saying that a while back and
again they submitted a fist to OSS a
fiscal impact statement in January
there's no IP submitted they don't meet
again until June 13th so my expectation
without having an opportunity to speak
to a member of the board is that that
would be the soonest they would even
file the IP if the board's meeting
sounds like the board's meeting
quarterly at best correct and they don't
really deal with it very well yeah if I
um yeah just to clarify for myself
whether it was um because we're just
cleaning things up the way that we've
been cleaning them up to make them
consistent or whether or not we're
filling in the blanks for a board that's
just not doing what it should be
doing maybe a little of column A a
little of column B because I also see in
light of what happened last year with
655 where the office was given all the
procedural this is something that slides
right into that very neatly I I think
which is why we are absolutely happy to
take it on if that's the committee's
decision where and just I want to go
back to the repeal do we want to repeal
these sections because I don't think we
do I think we want to repeal two of them
the third one we might want to leave or
relocate it to somewhere else
represent black and goalie I think um
think we it it's under the installation
housing board if we're going to give the
authority to oplc I would say we we keep
the repeal as it is but we're going to
have to take at least some variant on
Section 11 of 205 D20 and put it in this
thing at least to give them some
guidance on their ruling correct correct
believe that yeah okay so so we're in
agreement that if we decide to implement
this
program that Roman 11 needs to be
repealed because it's a wrong place but
the content needs needs to be put back
somewhere else more
appropriate okay we
will what about just a reference to the
CFR right at the manufactured housing
dispute resolation pursuant to CFR
whatever the citation is we could find
it and plug it in there do we I'm sure
we will take that into consideration in
the sub commmittee
um I don't know any uh any
volunteers
um
who's that doesn't have
one well it it's really uh it will be
subcommittee all right all right we'll
give this to representative grota and
her organization because it really is
dealing with the impacts of the
oplc changes that we've
made all
right
now that we've got that threshed out
does anyone else wish to testify on
Senate Bill
306 all right seeing n I'll close the
public hearing and we have 12 minutes
so all right we do have the amendment to
Senate
Bill 337 if we want to consider that I'd
can
okay thank
so
so representative leus andl of
subcommittee do you you have a motion I
this okay um well we can discuss I'll
make a motion to adopt Amendment 1427 H
to SB
337 all right is there a second I'll
second okay and um just trying to get
so
um yeah the only yep yep yep yep okay so
that's fine and so basically um as we
discussed
earlier um
um instead of naming particular
certification
organizations it's going to leave it to
um there must be a reference to rule
making somewhere in the Bill yes it's
that's on line nine of the bill it's not
in the amendment it's unchanged right uh
actually
line as amended by the Senate looks like
line 14 oh you're right
sorry yeah so that okay right so that it
would leave uh it up to oplc to decide
which certification programs are well to
the rul making process which is oplc and
everybody else who gets involved in it
um which I think is a lot better than
specifying particular ones that tends to
lead
to problems because if nothing else
those things change over time sometimes
okay represent bro you wish to speak to
your
second no I think representative luckus
did it perfectly okay anyone anyone else
concerns all right and that case the
motion is to adopt Amendment 1427 H to
Senate Bill
337 and the clerk can call the RO
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative
Gard votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes and the chair yes
11 y your name all right representative
leus I'd like to move um ought to pass
with an amendment on house uh Senate
Bill
okay is it second by representative
Simon
Okay do you wish to speak to the motion
all I think we've said it all unless
someone has other issues with it okay
repres
Simon well Madam chair I would just say
if for some reason the music therapist
bill doesn't pass this year this might
be a an alternative way to go about
doing
it seems like it's a a good model where
we don't have to put full VI insure in
place but they can still get what they
need
for
insurance
thank you that's a good point this is a
a purely
voluntary uh certification that uh one
can get or
not all right any um other comments
questions concerns represent
Gart just as far as the new hiring that
the oplc will be required to implement
this I don't know why $100,000 was stuck
in my mind but this is saying program
assistant to to it goes up to 73,000 in
fiscal year 2027 but what I'm having an
issue with is the numbers so the Dual
licensing on the bottom in the fiscal
note it'll say 30 licenses at $300 and
every two years of renews and then until
2027 they say 34 licenses and then for
the lactation service provider there's
50 licenses to begin with and then it
claims there'll be 60 licenses two years
later in 2027 but from the testimony we
received there was 221 clc's in the
state so
is this to say that there's only going
to be a fraction of the actual available
people that go through the certification
or by point being is we're looking at a
$50,000 difference between what the
license fees bring in and what it's
going to cost implement this now does it
make sense or no I missing something yes
it's a valid question the thing is that
this is a voluntary
certification and for example the clc's
who are working in the wi Wick offices
under 100% federal funds don't need need
a license someone that is already
licensed as a nurse may not or a PA or
whatever may not need an additional
license or additional certification if
they've got the um so there there may be
fewer than there are fewer
certifications given out than there are
actual practitioners okay follow up then
the would now oplc is self funded right
the fees pay for the salaries so would
this not be
a would this not be penalizing other
license holders now to cover that
difference am I missing and I understand
the oplc is in the process of revising
its license fees and the $300 for
example is an estimate it's not not set
Sone we have we haven't we're not
specifying what the license has to be
they can figure it out depending on the
number of applicants so it would balance
out to cover that at least it should it
the goal is that they should cover a
little bit more than their direct
cost represent leus and then represent
Simon yeah this is um related I
mean and I don't know if anyone here can
answer it um but it's saying they're
going to need additional
staff but I would think that would
depend on how many people actually asked
for this so I I assume they'll sort that
out but I mean
if if they these staff costs and their
estimate of the number of people they
would have to drastically increase the
licensing fee I would think to pay for
it I mean like a lot like more than 10
times 3,000 I
mean yes that's it seems it it does seem
like consistent I don't know if that's
yeah Douglas oer how oplc I think this
is kind of a worst case scenario fiscal
Network sheet we don't know how many
people we're going to get and depending
on what the turnout is we may need
somebody we may not but I wouldn't see
it taking more than one extra
position so this is the maximum I would
think so maximum expenses minimum
Revenue what a followup on that followup
yes but I mean it's showing here let's
say for
25 24,000 in revenue and over 69,000 in
cost so it mean you're going to have to
that's looking like $800 licensing fees
or something crazy like that unless if
this is what
happens that's something we're going to
have to
consider I I mean I don't have I don't
have an answer for you right now on that
right but we have we have the fee
setting Authority in the
102s um if we get this
Certification depending on the turnout
the amount of work
involved we may have to hire an
additional person and if the boards are
required to cover their costs uh
then fees are probably going to have to
go
up black can can I also say one more
thing I'm not the finance guy okay so
take everything I'm saying with a grain
of salt please I do know that the oplc
has fee setting Authority and I was
Lindsay is in the process of revising
the fees for the different Prof
profession they're breaking it out more
accurately than the office spends so
much and there's so many licenses that's
$155 each you're breaking it down more
uh more specifically to which boards
charge what okay follow up follow up
there so I mean if they have to hire
somebody that it doesn't necessarily
mean 100% of their time is going to be
on this it could do other things they
wouldn't have to cover all of that
position cor there's there's very few
people who are devoted to just one board
or one license
type good timing
speak of the devil represent simonk you
madam chair since this is a voluntary
license it wouldn't be spread out over
everybody correct but that wouldn't be
spread out over all C see it's just
people who are getting the voluntary
license and my assumption would be that
um they would have to make a cost
benefit analysis for themselves if if
getting money from Medicaid is worth it
to them then they'll pay the $300 to get
the reimbursement out of it it's a it's
cost for right now they can't get that
money at all so it's cost cost benefit
analysis okay represent Gard just for
curiosity sake has there ever been a s i
mean somebody on that's been on this
committee for longer might know this has
there ever been a voluntary license that
any I've only been here for 16
years Madam yes representative Simon I I
mean just from a philosophical
theoretical standpoint I would say the
process for doing that would be no
different than going from no license to
a full license it's still going to have
to come back in front of us correct yes
we're still going to have to vote on it
it would still have to pass it to the
legislature still so it's not like a it
might be like a from a philosophical
standpoint oh well we already have this
it's an camel's nose Under the Tent as
we like to say um but it's it would
require the same process as it as it
does
now okay
anyone else represent Brown thank you
madam chair
so is it possible that if if this passes
as it is and oplc has the right to
change that price for the license that
then the cost benefit analysis would
then drive all these people that wanted
decision yes it's possible thank
you unlikely but possible okay all right
representative
Goldie want to question the fact
that it says
that in order to
uh create the uh a new obligation for
oplc certify individuals and two
occupational things to administer this
May and and when I look at the numbers
down below for 30 lenses the high and I
continue to question that that for 30
lenses that's 80 sorry there's that's 30
duelist plus 50 cation people for 80
you're still looking at substantial fee
because that's that's only covering the
assistant never mind everything else
that goes
on do they really state that they need
that position if we do this
program or should it may have to
director Courtney can you help us with
this so I think the CH lindsy Cory
executive director
oplc um So currently we allocate
um most of the expenses I I take a step
back most of the expenses would likely
be related to licensing and per and
Licensing only um until we started to
see whether or not they're um using
enforcement related resources
so right now we have um a shared cost
model as it relates to licensing
resources there are handful of boards
that have dedicated staff just given the
volume um but what we're seeing is that
as we add on additional licensing
requirements and more licensing
requirements our staff our existing
staff can only handle so much so it is
possible that we would need an
additional resource it is also possible
given the volume which we have no clue
how many people would seek
certification that that cost could be
shared um with other license types um
but it's not clear at this point because
we just have no knowledge of of who
would seek
certification and I think we just wanted
to capture um for transparency purposes
maybe May was the better approach um but
I think we wanted to capture that
additional staff support could be
needed
all right thank you represent Simon you
have a comment yeah unless I'm wrong I
mean just because it says would need
doesn't mean that they have to right
you're not obligated to just because it
says
W it's a it's just the fiscal not right
yeah it's not we're not um we're not
actually was it authorizing any funding
or any position so uh we're just being
warned that it might require some right
okay all right any further comments
correct it's pity all the important
stuff seems to go over onto the back
page any other
comments all right in that case the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on Senate Bill 337 and the clerk can
call the role
represent Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
represent Gard
no clerk votes yes representative Boyd
yes then Brown yes representative
groa yes repres goalie yes repres Shu
yes and the clerk the chair I'm
sorry I don't need the promotion
yes all right so we have 10 yay one nay
all right do you object to uh consent do
you care you're not obviously writing a
Minority Report in that case all right
anyone else object to consent all right
we will put this on consent
representative leus will write a a
committee report at his earliest
convenience and we'll close the
executive session and open the hearing
on Senate
Bill 486
and I Mr bossy I believe is speaking for
the
senator thank you madam chair members of
the committee thank you for being such
gracious hosts to me all day I remain
Grant bossy with the New Hampshire
Senate here to introduce Senate Bill 486
on behalf of Senator Pearl the Bill's
Prime sponsor many Healthcare Providers
enjoy the benefits of participating in
multi-state compact Acts including
Physicians nurses psychologists physical
therapists speech therapists
occupational therapists and counselors s
sp46 would adopt a similar compact for
physician assistance this is part of the
ongoing effort much of it coming through
this committee to streamline the
occupational licensing process in New
Hampshire without sacrificing patient
safety we're a small state so no one is
very far from a border this bill will
make it easier for PAs to practice in
more than one state helping to attract
and retain skilled healthcare workers
Maine Vermont New York and Rhode Island
are considering PA compact legislation
this year so far five states have
already adopted the compact two more set
to sign by the end of the week thus
seven states is the minimum required for
the PA licensure compact to go live
passing this bill now would get New
Hampshire in at the beginning of the
compact giving the granite state a role
in the initial rules governing the
agreement to be clear the bill does not
change the scope of PA practice in New
Hampshire or any other state only the
legislature and Board of Medicine can do
that any PA from another state would
still be held to all applicable New
Hampshire laws and regulations New
Hampshire would still have the authority
and ability to investigate outof State
Pas practicing under the compact license
I will defer questions to the subject
matter experts here today if you have
any questions that they can't answer
I'll make sure Senator Pearl gets you an
answer Senator Pearl thanks you for your
consideration and support of Senate Bill
486 thank you
thank
you
questions no I think Cas you're off the
Perry chair members of the committee for
the record Warren Perry Deputy agent
General New Hampshire's Department of
military Affairs and V and services
again I'll be brief uh the department of
military Affairs and veteran services
sees these compacts as an advantage for
the military Community for two reasons
one it increases the portability of
licenses for uh for military members and
their families who move to New Hampshire
who might be Physicians assistants and
two it has a potential to increase the
number of providers in the state to care
for the service members veterans and
families of the State of New Hampshire
so with that I'll end my testimony and
allow the committee to get on with its
great work and I'm happy to answer any
questions that uh you may have okay
thank you I repres
go thank you madam chair
um doesn't we heard Senate Bill 485
addressing uh military spouses and
service members and
Licensing wouldn't that
suffice I I think it would except this
would uh it would in some instances and
maybe not in others right so I think
that the real Crux of 485 uh that we
heard earlier today if I get the numbers
right is uh if they only they allow the
digital verifications of Licensing so it
doesn't necessarily mean they would be
the state would be participating in a
compact which would be a little bit
different right so we would say I think
485 is more about issuing permanent
licenses in the state of New Hampshire
by verifying with a digital means this
is allowing Physicians assistants to
have to be licensed in multiple States
so I think there's some Nuance there I
don't think that I don't think it's
redundant there may be some overlap but
I don't think the two bills are
redundant thank you other
questions represent
Simon for Physicians assistance in
particular what would be the necessity
to be licensed in multiple States at the
same time for veterans in
particular I just think it increases the
you know the ability to practice right
so if they like like uh you know Mr
bossy had mentioned earlier if all the
border states have them we could
practice across state lines I think
there anyone else thank you very
Sims
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee again for the record my
name is Sarah Lesley and I'm a licensed
position assistant in the town of
Deerfield I'm the vice president of the
New Hampshire Society of Pas as well as
the legislative committee co-chair for
the society um thank you for allowing
Carl up here with me for to make things
a little bit more expedited for you all
um I'm here on uh this after on behalf
of nispa and over the over a thousand
Pas in New Hampshire and the students of
Masters of PA programs at Franklin
Pierce and mass College of Pharmacy and
Health Sciences nispa supports s486
which would have New Hampshire join the
PA licensure Compact and we did submit a
letter for the
record I know this committee has heard
plenty about Pas over the last few weeks
and now has a firm grip on the thousands
of hours of rigorous education training
required of a PA before they're
certified and licensed in New Hampshire
and state Nationwide and the committee
now knows how PA practice in medicine in
modern collaborative Healthcare teams in
hospitals Medical Offices urgent carees
community health centers nursing homes
uh workplace clinics throughout the
state and the nation we also serve in
the nation's uniform uh services and
work for other federal government
agencies such as the Department of
Veteran Affairs s SP 486 is the final
piece of the parody puzzle for Pas U as
it would have Pas join other healthcare
providers who enjoy the benefits of
Multistate multi-state licensure
compacts including Physicians and nurses
Nisa is thrilled to have Carl here in
person to testify in more detail and
address concerns raised by the committee
on other compact bills for other
provider groups but I won't go into the
details since they already um talked
about the uh you the benefits of the
Compact and what it would do so I'll
spare you the details to say that all
over again since start been presented to
you once already um but I'll uh pass it
now chair McGuire and members of the
committee my name is Carl Sim I'm a
deputy program director with the council
state governments the council state
governments is a nonpartisan membership
organization that serves the three
branches of state governments uh
specifically for interstate compacts
provide policy support to states on the
consideration of interstate compacts uh
as well as helping with the
administration of them as well for the
PA compact I just wanted to note a few
things but I primarily want to be here
as a resource for the committee to
answer any questions that they might
have uh but I would want to note that
the PA compact is similar in Form and
Function to several the other compacts
that New Hampshire is a member of
including the counseling compact
occupational therapy and the physical
therapy compact also like to note that
the PA compact like other ler compacts
enhances public protection by providing
for a specific mechanism through a data
system by which compact member states
May communicate about their ly
information to share information and
particularly with anything with adverse
actions or disciplinary investigative
information allowing States a a quick
and seamless way to be able to
communicate so that if actions need to
be taken in their specific State uh they
may do so in expeditious manner also
would like to note that the PA compact
can be complimentary to other leure
portability policies that states might
have um so where other leure portability
policies are namely there to help
support for those who want to practice
in a state a compact helps those uh
practitioners who wish to provide their
service in the state but also helps your
existing lenses as well to be able to uh
practice in other compact member states
uh in a more expeditious and streamlined
manner uh again I would like to you know
be here as a resource for the committee
for any questions so um happy to do so
and thank you the committee for their
time thank you Mr representative Simon
thank you madam chair um so we passed a
bill through the house last week or the
week before um dealing with the um
supervisory agreements that are required
for Pas at the moment the the future of
that bill is still uncertain it's
heading to the
Senate we don't know what the government
Governor would do it if those agreements
were still in place would the ability to
cross state lines for Pas and practice
in different states at the same times
complicate the ability for PAs to get
those supervisory agreements would they
be less attractive to positions um
because they'd be liable in multiple
States I can say that for the purpose of
the compact it it mirrors how states are
currently regulating PA so knowing that
there's differences across States about
um collaboration agreements super
provision require requirements Pas are
already having to abide by those
differences in laws so what the pa
compact does is it provides a a
streamline manner for them to be able to
um be able to apply for practice in
other compact member states provides a
mechanism so they can um understand
those differences in state laws so for
example compact member states can make
as a requirement that Pas take and pass
a jurist Prudence exam uh so they can
differences follow up follow up so just
in case I didn't follow there correctly
like all the way through um are you un
I'm not sure if you addressed as what
I'm saying are you unsure as to whether
or not it would make it less attractive
for Physicians to sign those
collaborative agreements because they're
going to be working across state lines
under multiple
jurisdictions does the compact cover
that essentially the compact would only
allow for obtaining compact privilege it
wouldn't change how the PA if a PA comes
from Massachusetts and they apply for
compact privilege in New Hampshire they
would still have to then abide by the
state law in New Hampshire so if it say
h1222 doesn't pass they would still have
to then find a physician to sign that
form um
so that that would be the same hurdle
that we're facing now whether you get a
compact privilege or not or if you're
actually in New Hampshire trying to work
you still have to make sure that you're
employer or you have to find your own
collaborating physician so the compact
wouldn't change wouldn't make it I don't
think it would make it harder would just
present more Pas that would be licensed
or privileged in the state that would
then have to find a physician to sign
their form does that answer your
question or I can represent broa and
then
goalie so my understanding of a compact
is that those states that are early
participator who participate early in
the program are the ones that set the
criteria and the requirements for the
compact for the compact license so I
don't believe
that
what I'm thinking and what you're saying
is in is in Conflict so my understanding
is that the compact would set the
requirement and if the compact
requirement was that Pas had to signed
collaborative agreements then the P that
are in New Hampshire who want to be part
of the compact would have to have
collaborative agreements mean they would
have to be or it could be the other way
that they don't have to have a
collaborative agreement so this is where
I think we need to this out because I I
we're seeing two different things I mean
of our knowledge of compacts those
states
that for example it says that currently
five states have adopted the compact
right what we don't
know um is we don't know how many states
oh it says seven states need to enact
the Compact and once that compact is
enacted those seven states get together
and write the licensing criteria and the
criteria for having a licensed
compact is that correct I mean that's
the way we understand it yes thank you
for the question so in the compact
legislation that defines the parameters
at which the commission can operate
through rulemaking so it dictates what
the state requirements are to join as
well as what the individual requirements
are for a PA to use the compact if they
are in a compact member State the
compact commission which is made up of
uh Representatives um licensing board
administrators or board members from
compact member states they can engage in
Ru making uh but it must be narrowly
confined to what's authorized in the
compact legislation so uh that includes
things such as um you know if there is a
you know uh data set requirements to
further refine that what's based in the
compact uh but they can't unilaterally
change those conditions that are already
represented in the legislation um and
also just wanted to to note one other
thing that actually we're currently at
six compact member states um so one
closer uh Nebraska uh um joined it
yesterday so just wanted to share that
news yes we have a report from our
researcher but it was from Monday
so represent
chair when we talk about these compacts
and Healthcare
compacts I look at specifically when I
look at these compacts is the nursing
Compact and I see it as it has been
nothing but a driver of increased health
care costs due to the fact
that once this was passed we have these
outside organizations
that hire travel nurses and just send
them around the state for the top dollar
that they can get filling in positions
that cannot be filled and I don't
see any state out there with a surplus
of nurses it's just the reallocation of
services is as to who can go where to
get more
money
and when I see that it's it just bothers
me we see it in our County nursing homes
all the time when we can't fill
positions and the costs going up with
travel nursing can you how can you show
me that this same scenario won't happen
in this
compact so I can say a few things to
that that question and appreciate the
concern uh one is that this compact is
different in for and function to the
nurse lure compact which essentially
employs a driver's license model so you
have a multi-state license you can apply
for through the compact that lies in
each compact member State uh there is a
mechanism through this compact where a
PA who qualifies can purchase a
privilege to practice that authorization
practice in other compact member states
for each state they want to practice in
so uh there isn't that kind of uni
access to um other compact member states
um also just say from experience um with
with other compacts um we haven't yet
seen anything with that you know that
direct um you know correlation or data
showing that increased in in kind of
health care costs um the the one data
point that we can um point to and these
compacts are still fairly inexistent so
there's studies being done is for the
interstate medical lecture compact which
did show an increase in providers for
compact member
states
follow just I I need to make a statement
that I think all of here that have
County nursing homes can say that it
costs
okay
repres when you say that this bill this
compact is different I thought all
compacts use the same boiler
plate so there are some differences
between compacts that need to be
responsive to the needs of the
profession how States currently regulate
them so while there is some shared uh
boilerplate language that might exist in
the compact U particularly in the latter
section of the compact um there are
differences in how a compact um operates
um with you know again some similarities
but uh for example in that the way that
someone would be able to access the
compact for the PA is different than it
would be for Physicians and
nurses so I I be happy to explain any of
the uh the more details in those
needed not seeing uh
a lot of demand for that so thank you
are there any other
questions thank you for your
Courtney afternoon Lindsay Courtney
executive director oplc um I will try to
keep this brief um you probably know
what I'm going to say anyways um and I
think I can Echo uh the reason s why you
hire should adopt the physician
assistant lure compact um as the same
reasons that are previous speakers have
said but I would like to respond to a
couple of the questions um that have
come up from the committee um the first
being that um I think there was a
question representative Simon about um
you know essentially why why would
military service members or their
spouses need this and I think that um
there's always need for portability
particularly in the healthcare sector
given the changes in the delivery um so
we no longer see the model consistently
where patients go physically go to their
their provider and they have an
appointment and then they go home and
that provider is located in New
Hampshire um often times we see
providers engaging in teleah health
practice crossb practice and so if you
have a a person who's you know typically
residing in New Hampshire um um
traveling down to for example Boston to
see their uh provider but then decides
we're going to have a tele Health visit
maybe their imuno compromise whatever
the need is they need a New Hampshire
license in order to have that tele
Health visit um the uh physician
Practice Act exempts um certain
scenarios from needing a license the PA
Practice Act does not and I'm not aware
of any other exemptions for that sort of
uh scenario so there is a need for
portability particularly given the
change in delivery models another
example would be in the mental health
world we see that with people who
specialize in psychiatric care you know
if somebody's on vacation or traveling
college students we saw that during the
pandemic there was a need for people to
get licensed quickly in order to
maintain continuity of care so I think I
would view it um less about having
multiple different jobs uh across state
lines but more about
um being able to continue to treat
existing patients uh wherever they may
be um is a reason why we need
portability and compacts provide um one
mechanism for portability there was a
question about the CH the difference
between this Compact and the nurse lure
compact what I would say is there are
generally two compact models one is the
driver's license model that we see with
nurses provides greater flexibility less
administrative burden but there's less
oversight by the state because you don't
know who's practicing in your state the
majority of compacts are modeled after
what we see in physical therapy that
require comp compact privilege you know
who's practicing in your state and
that's this model the substance is
essentially the same in terms of
boilerplate language and I know we've
talked about it in the past with social
work um and other compact bills um but
the model is different in the sense that
you have to get permission or
authorization that privilege to practice
there was um I think a question did you
say that someone who is licens under the
compact needs the permission of each
state to practice in that state yeah so
essentially they go through the um and
the permission has to be given right but
they go they typically go through
whatever the body is the commission is
for for physical therapy as fsbt they
the person has a streamlined application
they apply through the fsbt and the
compact privilege is issued but it's
issued specific to each state in which
they're going to practice um that's not
my personal favorite in terms of a model
but it does provide a little bit more
oversight by the state because they can
then tack on additional requirements
Juris prent of contain education um
there's also a revenue Source associated
with that um there was a question about
collaborative practice agreements and
the way I would look at lenser
requirements versus collaborative
practice as as the compact sets forth
the lure requirements but it's not going
to change the scope of practice and
whether whether a physician assistant is
required to have a collaborative
practice agreement is required to be
supervised or can independently practice
is a scope of is really a scope of
practice question we see that with aprns
New Hampshire is fairly unique and that
we allow for independent provider status
if they go to New Hampshire they don't
have that same Stat or Massachusetts
they don't have that same status it
doesn't mean that they don't they can't
get licensed or that the requirements
aren't the same because they're likely
identical it's a scope of practice issue
so the compact's not going to dictate
the collaborative practice question um
or answer to that question because
that's very comparable to the scope of
practice I think those are the things
that I I wanted to address um I guess
lastly I would say that the goal of or
the objective of the licensing boards is
to protect the public um and I would say
that of the different models for
portability and we've seen several in
this state compacts provide greater
public protection because of the
requirement to exchange information with
other states so if somebody's coming in
from
California um and they're requesting a
single state license for you know via
the pathway um this committee um past
last session HB 594 we're going to
verify that license but we are really
relying on their attestations that they
don't have anything pending and they
don't have any other licenses in another
state we're in the dark there's no
there's no system um when you're part of
a compact you're required if you know
there's a significant investigative
information you're required to
essentially make that available subject
to state law um under uh for your for
compact uh participants uh for your
States so it's more protective of the
public because you get a a fuller
picture of what's happened with that
particular licy to see whether they're
form shopping if they're just going from
state to state to state before they can
be disciplined and I think in that sense
it's more protective of the public and
why we as administrators really like
compacts versus other mechanisms for
portability happy to answer any other
questions you may have thank you are
there questions represent br
said that
compacts provide more safety than than
what than other mechanisms for
portability okay but that doesn't mean
it provides more safety to the public
than what we have now in the state like
for example
oplc what I'm saying is we believe that
being part I believe that being part of
the compact provides the office with
more information necessary to be able to
make the decisions um as to whether or
not you know somebody should be licensed
or we need to proceed down a
disciplinary route um than we currently
have under our existing statutory
structure
Simon thank you madam chair I I probably
have more questions than the director
would care to answer at this particular
point in time um but um and having made
that joke I forgot all of my questions
um
going back to my initial question start
with that what need would there be for a
physician's assistant outside of
potentially um telea medicine to
practice in multiple States at the same
time where this would be helpful to them
like how are they practicing in Nebraska
and New Hampshire at the same time um
that would be my first question and just
quickly with a followup on that um how
long does it take to get a license in
the state of New Hampshire right now and
what's it costing a PA to get that
license so the cost
$175 um if they submit a complete
application um we can turn that around
in a business day the the longest
processing time is due to receiving an
incomplete licensing application and the
FBI criminal history check that's
required that's still taking about two
weeks so once we get that we can process
it very quickly um the first part of
okay the scenarios in which I mean so
this is very unlike nurses we don't see
see we don't see the same level um of
travel assignments with Pro with
providers than we do with nurses um so
there so what we see the why we see the
need for multiple licenses is truly the
the delivery uh model and the changes in
the delivery models um for military
families though and this is why the
Department of Defense has really funded
these initiatives is that often times
you know we see the spouses are licensed
as a physician assistant and they get
orders and they have to move quickly and
they'd like to be able to find a job and
often in healthcare you can't even um
you know you can't finalize a job offer
until you can demonstrate that you're
were licensed um so that's a challenge
as well with a compact they could they
would know for certain that they they
have a job opportunity because they're
able to get licensed through um through
the compact quickly
follow up and then we'll see anybody
else has sounds good um I'll I'll forgo
my first followup then I go to my second
one um is
there we've we've started to approve
these compacts and now everybody wants a
compact I mean we're getting a compact
from everybody is there evidence that
the compacts that we've put in place
already are delivering the results that
we're hoping for and I just I I guess I
would refer back to the um social worker
compact that we just discussed and and I
wish I had thought to ask the question
at the time but people were talking
about how they were not allowed to give
continuance of care but the but all of
the examples that they were giving were
examples in which it seemed like the
person that they were
servicing ended up without a significant
negative impact for their inability to
have the continuance of care we didn't
have any testimony of self harm or
suicide or anything like they didn't
come forward with that kind of
information and when I asked I did ask
for whether or not there was evidence
that the psychology compact was meeting
its stated goals whether it was
producing those good outcomes I didn't
receive any of that information and now
I've got a physician's assistance
contact and and I feel like we're just
continuing to push these things through
because they maybe sound good or because
there's some level of portability to
them but without receiving I'm never
receiving any evidence that they're
actually accomplishing what they're set
out to accomplish we've already pulled
out of one of them so can you put my
mind at isas a little bit on that yeah
so I would I know um Mr Sims from um CSG
referenced uh some studies there's
limited studies um and I don't think
cypa is the best example because I I I
of all the compacts that's the one I I I
I'm not a fan of um mainly because it's
a limited in scope it only applies to
Tele health so I don't know why you
would structure it that way but the
reason why we're seeing an increase in
the number of compacts is because the
Department of Defense has put some funds
behind it because they recognize that it
it benefits military families and
particularly spouses so that's why we're
seeing the development and I would say
that it takes a couple of years to get a
compact up and running so counseling we
joined I think two years ago we're not
even issuing privileges yet so it's
really still premature I think to be
able to have data anecdotally I will say
though um I mean my experience managing
oplc throughout the pandemic um without
the nursing compact I there's no this
state uh would have been in much worse
shape and I know that we're not in great
shape right now um you know
representative go brought up the nursing
home shortage and certainly there isn't
a massive surplus of nurses anywhere but
um but I think the but I I continue to
receive but less frequently so but
particularly during Co and
thereafter would receive calls weekends
nights midnights we have we have no
staff we're going to have to shut down
what do we do with our patients I need
to bring in this person um from
professions that weren't nursing and the
fact that nursing people who are part of
the compact could just come into the
state and accept a travel assignment for
20 days uh to meet an urgent short-term
need really really anecdotally helped
New Hampshire um that's just my personal
opinion based on what we were seeing
throughout the pandemic what we saw with
Mental Health Professions for example I
mean we um I mean I think we increased
the number of psychologists overnight
under an emergency license by
65% um which is insane which
demonstrated the crossb practice that
was happening and while we we may not
seem harm from continuity of care it's
actually an ethical violation for
somebody to abandon their client and so
what they're faced with is a question of
do I discontinu care so as to comply
with the law and not provide unlicensed
practice which technically is a crime
whether it should be you know is a
question maybe you should consider but
um but or or um do I abandon my client
and um commit an ethical violation which
could subject me to uh charges of
professional
misconduct sorry okay representative
goalie and then gr thank you madam chair
and just I need to go back to the
reference of during covid and being able
to get those nurses up here in New
Hampshire travel nurses that we
needed could you tell me what state out
there had a surplus to give out I mean
because every nurse we took in was
leaving a hole somewhere else and that's
the issue I have with these
compacts I guess what I would say is uh
we don't have the same ratio nurse to
population that throughout the state we
also have an aging population um more so
than other states so it's possible that
our need might be greater given uh our
aging population so I don't
think we don't again we don't have the
same ratio of nurses to to um the
general population throughout the
country so we clearly were drawing
people in um for short term assignments
now of course the the model is not great
because you're paying a lot of money um
and people can't can't keep up and that
of course is a challenge that this
legislature has um tried to solve
particularly with the nurse registry uh
the nursing agency registry that you
passed last year I don't know what the
long-term solution is other than to
focus on Pipeline which is something
that you know our agency along with
other agencies and stakeholders are
working on but what is clear is that we
brought people in we may have been
paying them but the alternative was what
to not bring them in and then we
all I
guess one of the answers
is the problem to solve is how do we get
more healthcare workers instead of
compacts where states
are divided about
amongst themselves on whoever is going
to pay the top dollar to bring in the
individuals and that's where I guess
philosophically we differ in these
compacts I think we need to step back
look at the long-term effects of the
compacts that are out there now carry
before we continue to keep going into
more and more compacts not knowing what
the real ramifications are I don't think
we disagree on the philosophy I think I
don't think it can be either or though
approach I guess that's my my opinion I
think we can do both at the same time
and we should do both at the same time
but for example you know Medical Imaging
that's a license type that we have in
New Hampshire we don't it's not other
states don't have that license type but
we have it here um and because of the
criminal history record check
requirement we can't we've we've changed
that subsequently with a temporary
license but at the time we couldn't
issue a license we'd wait the two weeks
we had entire emergency department
shutting down not being able to doing
Imaging for patients even though they
had a traveler who was willing to accept
an assignment so what a compact does is
that it gets rid of that twoe window so
when we're in this crisis situation we
can actually put somebody in there to
work to continue to provide care while
we work on the long-term solution which
I agree with you there has to be a
solution which is you know pipeline
getting more people involved but I don't
think it's an either
or
so I've been under the impression
that the compact is a boilerplate
document and can't be amended but this
is not the case is that because I was
just told that this compact is different
from other compacts I think there are
two different things you can't amend
this language because every state you
can or can cannot cannot because every
state has to adopt the same language
because it's both a cont ract and a
piece of legislation and if you don't
adopt the same language you're not
there's no meaning of the minds
essentially um this compact I think what
U Mr Sims was saying was we were talking
about nursing which has a different
model in terms of the driver's license
model you get one license and uh you can
go anywhere and you don't even have to
notify the state that you're there
that's one model the other model is the
majority of other licens or compacts
like physical therapy speech uh I think
psychology as well where you have to you
have to let the state know you're there
and that's the privilege model but under
either scenario which this is the
privilege model you can't change the
document
okay all right other questions represent
Simon thank you madam Char I just
realized my mic's been on this whole
time um so when we're when we're looking
at Co in particular because obviously
was a different set of circumstances
than in general um would emergency
orders from the governor have allowed
for lure to be given in emergency
situations even though it didn't comply
licensure yeah so we did do that and
we the executive branch took the
position that executive orders pursu to
a state of emergency could override
legislative
requirements um and so we did do that
and originally um I think early on um
the state had considered just allowing
people who are licensed elsewhere to
practice here but then you get into the
reimbursement issue and so we had to
issue
licenses um and we were able to turn it
around fairly quickly um but of course
you know even today we still have issues
um with certain professions with just
having an urgent need particularly for
Imaging um and there is no state of
emergency and there's no ability to wave
those wave those requirements so um but
yes we did do that we issued over 22,000
licenses under the state of
emergency thank
you g Harden then
Brown thank you madam chair from what
I'm understanding the real issue is the
federal government is taking too long to
get these background checks done two
weeks you say whereas your department
can turn around one
day so if we could have background
checks done quickly there would be no
need for these which I consider kind of
an roundabout attempt for a national ID
it seems like but what anyway is that
basically what you're saying
though I think that compacts do provide
a a faster way to getting a license
through a privilege um and rather than
having to do you know criminal history
record check everywhere depending on the
model you you know you can just do it
once um
the the feds yeah I mean so there's a
multip step process here right it and
and part of the issue with criminal
history record checks and there's some
national legislation that's been filed
to try to resolve this it's probably not
going to go anywhere um but it the way
it works is the person has to get
fingerprinted and then the safety has
staff members and they have to be have
very specific training and they have to
essentially approve of the fingerprint
and then it goes off to the f bi and
then it comes over and we and we get a
print out certainly if they could do
that faster that would be nice um there
is a uh a wraback program available to
law enforcement agencies but the pro the
challenge is we are not a law
enforcement agency I wouldn't I wouldn't
suggest we should be one um so there are
additional opportunities available to
law enforcement agencies to get that
information back um but we are presently
I don't see any movement there current
ly representative
Brown thank thank you madam chair So
currently in 31016 where military
service members and their spouses and
this is really important kind of to
follow up on representative goalie and
with the deputy agitant
General this compact would make that
process for those coming here even
possibly more efficient than what's
under
so what yes correct yep absolutely okay
and follow up to that follow that would
ALS the compact would also make it then
easier for a a spouse or a military
person to go to another state that is
within the compact working more quickly
and more easily that's the point some of
part of the point right right and and
follow up again for military service
members to possi carry their provider
with them for an amount of time at least
till they find another provider in
another state correct if it's even if
you thank you madam chair provided that
the state that they came from or are
going to is a member of the compact
correct I mean the compacts are drafted
with the intent that all states are
going to adopt obviously that's not the
case but I do think counseling is
upwards of 40 and I think nursing is as
well um so there is an appetite uh for
for
compacts okay other
questions thank you very much for
Testimony appreciate it all
right does anyone else wish to testify
on Senate Bill
cousing
uh thank you madam chair for the record
Dave Cousy with Prospect Hill strategies
uh here on behalf of the society
physician assistants I just wanted to
clarify one uh or two points uh
questions from representative Simon uh
one from representative Simon and one
that was really uh the same from
representative Gro and representative
Simon first uh representative Simon I
think you asked a question regarding you
know why would you why does a PA in New
Hampshire and a PA Nebraska what's the
what's the rub I think the other thing
to keep in mind is the the regional
health systems especially in the small
states that we're in here so um you know
if you work for Dartmouth Hitchcock for
example um I I don't know this to be
100% fact but if they have operation if
they have an office in Vermont that you
may be employed and if it's you know
primary care or whatnot you're going to
be going back and forth but that re
regionalization of healthcare I think is
something we need to keep in mind so so
that uh these Healthcare employers can
have the flexibility for their um for
their employees if they need to have be
working in different states so that was
to that I think the most important thing
and the reason why I wanted to get
between the committee and going home was
just to give a very clear answer to the
question that you representative Simon
then representative Gro you followed up
on regarding the kind of the Nuance of
this Compact and how it pertains to
collaboration agreements so very clearly
anyone who's in this compact or any any
physician assistant but if in the
scenario where there's a compact a PA
licensed in the compact they want to
come to New Hampshire they need under
current law a collaboration agreement
signed with a New Hampshire licensed
physician period if they're coming from
a state uh for example Maine where there
is relaxed collaboration agreement rules
uh those employed in a healthcare
setting in Maine after 4,000 hours do
not need a collaboration agreement if
they were coming here under the compact
they would still need and they had
10,000 clinical hours of practice so
they didn't need one in Maine in their
employed setting they would need one
here under current law period um now the
the flip side which I think
representative groda may have been
asking about is what if a New Hampshire
PA that's under a collaboration
agreement of course under current law if
they went
to um Utah which I believe as a state
that after 10,000 hours you don't need a
collaboration agreement and they've been
practicing for 20 years then in Utah
that New Hampshire PA would not need a
collaboration agreement to practice
medicine in Utah but as soon as they're
back here they they can't practice
without that collaboration agreement
more important should uh HB 1222 become
law the requirement uh as the bill
passed the house that uh anyone uh
working either by themselves or in some
employment setting without a physician
with less than 8,000 hours of practice
time they need a collab they would need
a collaboration agreement in New
Hampshire under law there would be no
backdoor way for someone to come into
New Hampshire and and circumvent any
collaboration agreement laws either
current law or you know as proposed by
1222 so I wanted to make that make that
abundantly
clear okay when in Rome I guess is how
the how this would work for Pas okay
representative Simon and then
goalie sorry representative goalie um so
following they were answers to my
questions and I appreciate that follow
up on those though um so when it comes
to my question about whether or not it
would make it more difficult to get a
collaboration agreement in this model if
I'm reading you correctly you're saying
it wouldn't be more difficult but it
might be a whole lot more expensive
because a person when they're practicing
in New Hampshire would need a
collaboration in New Hampshire if they
wanted to also to practice in Maine they
need a separate collaboration agreement
in Maine they went to another state they
required a collaboration agreement they
would need a separate collaboration
agreement in that state is that correct
if those States required collaboration
agreements for that physician assistant
based on their laws and regulations if
it's clinical practice hours for
example in that scenario just speaking
in general the answer is yes they would
need three separate collaboration
agreements okay follow up super follow
up one yeah just one um so when we're
when we're talking about these kinds of
things you know we're obviously talking
a compact that would affect many states
but our our job here is just to focus on
the state of New Hampshire and and what
happens here um so my question on the
first part that you answered where
there's collaboration between states or
we're on a border you know Town whatever
when I'm looking at what we're providing
for the State of New
Hampshire it's
$175 and potentially a day plus criminal
records check turnaround from you having
a a license in here what is the net
benefit to the state of New Hampshire
from your perspective in that scenario
because it's not Nebraska right I mean
we're talking Vermont sure um what's the
net benefit to the state of New
Hampshire to not have those people
directly under licensure here as opposed
to under some collaboration agreement
that really is centered somewhere we
don't even know where at this particular
point in time um could give me a good
little guidance on that so I'll I'll do
the best I can although that could be be
better answered by Miss Leslie and Mr
Sims um I I as I understand it and I'm
just a lobbyist um but as I understand
it while notionally it can take a day or
two to turn around a license application
I I I believe that's not actually um in
most cases it takes uh a week or two uh
usually closer to two as I understand it
um and and maybe direct criminal
background checks uh well so the whole
so the whole process so yes Theory all
these things could you know the moon and
the sun because we're talking about the
eclipse we could get one of those and
it's could only be a day or two but we
do know that it takes longer uh so that
is a benefit
um is there um are there benefits you
know to shaving that those two weeks off
I you know I'm not I I I'm sure I could
come up on the Fly I wasn't prepared to
answer the question with some scenarios
where you have folks who may be
relocating to the area things along
those lines but we could get a a better
answer for that for you if you think and
we have some time I'm assuming so you
can get me some information happy thank
you for the question represent
gy thank you madam chair thank you for
taking the
question you mentioned earlier about
Regional areas like Dartmouth with
Vermont or wherever they may be right in
the area is
there
uh reciprocity or States getting to
reciprocity
agreements so I know I believe it was HB
540 P last year was the reciprocity law
um I believe the short answer is with
regard to PA licenses uh I'm not sure
how that is how that applies because
right now there is Board of Medicine uh
approval and things like that um maybe
director Courtney uh or if they're I
don't know if they've left they've left
they yeah no that's good uh why not let
the lobbyist squirm right no uh so I I
believe there could be in some instances
I don't know how that would specifically
apply here um it does get into the uh
the issue of similar similar
requirements and certifications and
whatnot which may be uh slightly
different when you're talking about uh
healthc care providers um you know
medical uh practitioners so I'll have to
get back to you on that representative
and thank you for the
question followup comment I wish you
know more
States while the
compact seems okay I think a lot of the
issues could be solved if we could get
back to these kind of agreements
reciprocities I think would help a lot
and I don't know why we're not re moving
that way yes Pro probably because the
other state has to be interested and
Vermont might be interested in
establishing reciprocity but
Massachusetts in general is not and
there's a lot more doctors and other
unfortunately they're not joining the
compacts either very
much yes yes so that's uh one of the
factors is that we're a very small
fish all right any other questions
represent Brown thank you madam
chair this is a question question and a
comment I guess so this would from a
tella Health perspective this would
apply to snowbirds that live in New
Hampshire seven months a year and maybe
elsewhere five months a year they could
maintain that PA relationship while
they're in that other state for five
months is that a scenario that would
benefit that is a scenario and that is
something that we see now with
Physicians and and nurses and therefore
nurse practitioners yes it seems obvious
to the rest of you probably but thank
you other questions
all right thank you very much mam chair
all right does anyone else wish to
486 not seeing anybody I'm going to
hearing and
this I don't know this I don't think
this needs a study committee we just
need
to
well I don't think it needs
a sure all right and that representative
broa suggests we go into executive
session and uh you would you like to
make a motion right I'd like to make a
motion of itl on this bill and I don't
uh how Senate Bill 43 486 all right
is there a
second well I'll second it
actually do you wish to speak to your
motion
yes um
because we have we're in a state of flux
ourselves with
Pas and we have um legislation that's
pending I don't know and we have this
other bill that we had earlier on the
military I don't know how much more we
need and I think that for right now we
can not pass this bill not have any
detriment effects to our state because
we can still accept
military I'm sure that the the Senate
bill that we had earlier Senate Bill 488
will pass so I think that we can just
sit with what we've got right now and
not go any further okay I'd like to add
that at the rate other states are
joining this
compact they'll be the commission will
be formed and they'll start putting out
the rules and we will have a much better
idea of what we're signing up for in a
year or two once the commission has been
formed and has a chance to work and I'm
not convinced that being in the first
few
States is enough to make up for the
detriment of signing up for things you
don't know about
representative leus and then gr I just
wanted to add to the list that
representative groa uh made is that we
uh passed a bill on reciprocity or
licensed by endorsement last year and
the rulemaking process is underway so
there's also that okay yes and since
this is going to be um licensing by
privilege that also gives this time
because people no matter what people
have to come here and ask for privilege
so
that makes it a different type of
compact not realizing that these are all
different kinds I think this is actually
something that allows New Hampshire to
sit back and
wait and I wish I had known about I wish
I had known about these kinds of
compacts
earlier
okay
ring thank you madam chair and I'll be
supporting the itl
um these compacts just keep coming one
after another like representative Simon
said earlier it's all of a sudden
everybody needs to be or wants to be in
a
compact but we have yet
to truly
see the full impact these compacts have
had we've heard that information out
there is still new as to what's going on
and what's happening
um
and this truly is not a compact yet
because they haven't formed in St
started working for it um so we're
signing up for something that we don't
know is going to happen like we've done
with numerous other compacts which I
wish we would have held off before we
get into um for th those reasons I'll be
supporting the itl okay representative
Brown uh thank you madam chair um I wish
I had all the history that all of you
folks do that makes it a little bit
easier for you to think about these
things
um because
for myself I'd like to talk about it
more and and learn more um I I hesitate
just to vote itl because I just don't
know enough the fact that this maybe
this would not help some of our veterans
and some of our our uh our residents
that are out of state for a short amount
of time so I I I I don't feel like I'm
well enough
informed can I tell you representative
Simon thank you madam chair uh
representative Brown I'd love to have a
C cup of coffee with you sometime we can
take an hour and talk over these
things well actually the the point is
that director Courtney specifically said
it takes a couple of years to get it
going and so if we were to join the
compact in a year or two that would give
you time to research and give them time
to develop the compact so that we do
know what we're we're agreeing to um
this is not
a not a a statement that we never want
to join this compact it's a statement
that we don't think it's in the best
interest of the state this
year that's that's fair thank you
represent sorry a serious comment this
time I think the other thing to keep in
in mind when we're looking at this is
and it's mid mentioned already I just
don't can't remember when we've done
such a tremendous amount of work over
the last two years to make it really
really really easy to get a license in
this state and we have reciprocity in
the works we have expediated lure in the
works we have the veterans bills that
we've been working on in the works we've
got a lot of irons in the fire and none
of them have landed yet like and to
allow our own systems that we've put in
place to solidify while we're waiting to
see what compact looks like just to me
seems like Common
Sense representative
sh Madam chair I just want to say that
represent Senator Brown we welcome you
back to this committee next
[Music]
term all
right all right other uh comments
questions all right the motion is in
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
486 and the clerk can call the rooll
representative Simon yes representative
leak yes representative Bailey yes
representative geard yes clerk vote Yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes and the chair yes 11 yay z
n all right that's the motion passes 11
to zero does anyone object to
consent I don't see anyone so I'll put
this one on consent and representative
grot your report at your earliest
convenience all right I don't think
we're ready for than any of the others
so thank you all for your input and
valuable knowledge and we will resume
next
Wednesday
e